framing attic could you give me a
confirmation when you get a chance right
now YouTube is OBS says know what it's
doing
I don't see let me know yeah all right
and we are live that wasn't part of the
live welcome to the Isle of our cast and
the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 146 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day I'm extremely excited
about our special guests and we've got
blood sweat and pixels PlayStation 5
pricing issues Geoff Keighley skipping
III and Phil Spencer's most recent
interview to discuss so we're gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord whom the ILP was extremely honored
to meet in the flesh with fellow Kotaku
colleague Lord Steven Sotelo and destiny
community manager Lord eh this Lord now
he represents the very pinnacle of video
game journalism but is also a beacon of
light in regards to investigative
reporting and of course our shared
passion of the destiny franchise
introducing the author of the national
bestseller blood sweat and pixels
co-host of the split-screen podcast and
news editor of kakaku.com
one of the most informative journalists
in the game yet still the most hardcore
Jets fan you'll ever know laughs from
the Empire State a very old New York
City and cried enough to make his debut
into the realm of the Lord's my man Lord
Jason Schreyer how you doing sir
I just like when it started getting
super Gandhi to appeal to hardcore
I thought I was a hardcore fan but not
hardcore enough for what destiny has
turned into oh but we could talk about I
got to ask you a little question but
we're definitely gonna get it to a man
absolute pleasure to have you in the
room you are Lord which she do so it's
only right we show you the proper
respect really quickly because I know
time is limited I just wouldn't know
what have you been playing lately so
I've been playing this game just started
so two games I'm talking about first of
all I've been playing this game called
enter the gungeon which is an old rogue
like like super addictive I didn't think
I would like it
tove into it because I'm writing I'm
working on the second book right now for
research purposes I need to play this
game and but really good and then I'm
playing this other game on switch that
I'm playing before bed it's called a V
aviary Avery aviary attorney aviary
attorney okay
it is about bird lawyers you play as
this this bird it's Sparrow okay good
it's like Phoenix right with birds ate
een 40s France it's an indie game it's
not it's not made by descent or anything
by a couple people and you go around
eighteen forties France and solve
murders and like defend in court
it's like Phoenix it's basically Phoenix
Wright gameplay except with birds and
it's it's it's very delightful
I enjoy no delve you look out for that
as well as the new publication we know
will be coming so you already know we
got the Four Horsemen of game sorry
apologies one second is saying that
Jason's Michael oh okay cool cool yeah
Jason if there's any way you can turn
yes that any greatly yes yes yes
oh damn much appreciate it but sunny now
if you mean to tweak anything else yeah
no doubt you're good you're good
so of course you know we still got the
original Four Horsemen of gaming those
written Wars in rum at the roundtable my
co-hosts with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror Lord of reveals and the house
of the young wolf my man Lord addict a
dog sir I am highly awakened you know
I've been playing got talk a couple
seconds King how you liking
bleeding-edge because that's what I
would play
and you know where it is I first of all
shout out shout out today to the 19,000
people that uh was a following that a
tweet that I put out yesterday it is so
much fun I'm trying I don't I'm limited
to these three days and I'm trying to
learn all these characters so I stuck
with one character that I love there's
the the little one got put up the teddy
bears character right now but I like
what they did no big Reena I wasn't able
to get that from III no no that is I
guess you know game pass break sure
makes you break your I won't can
participate in a baton out of respect
for her I definitely went 100 percent
into that beta and it's it's just it's a
game that I've been anticipating for so
long so yeah that rules definitely
nothing to be been broken destroyed and
throwing the bushes I don't owe a law
because time is limited and of course we
have our most radical Gabriel or the
solo game who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also
that's Astrid honest
mister or flower profile Illuminati and
lore patron of the iron baked mummy
Lord sovereign how you doing sir do a
good we did was it yesterday I saw blast
kovitch blasted somebody out of you it
was kind of crazy yeah that was kinda
crazy he went right foot for John so
that's good I mean Johnny's you're
different people to fight otherwise yeah
he's gonna need to move up cuz he just
he there's no
did he clean well John I'm gonna be
fighting a Madison Square Garden next
year the trajectory so precisely
you have the heavyweight members left in
that division you know might as well try
to get this shot in this but you know as
soon as possible no no no no anything
else just that yeah just plugging away
at UH at a fallen order um I downloaded
the the new DLC for dead cells the Batsy
but I haven't had a chance to play so I
definitely want to get into that
um and what else so yeah yesterday so
yesterday I I went to see them you did
the cinematic tour de force you know
that which is a video game oh okay okay
it was actually pretty good I took
little man to see it he enjoyed it um it
was actually a decent family's last kid
movie it was pretty well done and I
heard it was amazing from credit scenes
and everything it was a man those kids
loved him some Sonic that's that's what
I have to say yeah I'm definitely gonna
take my son on Monday and I mean I'm
going to get a chance to watch that and
you know because I'm a sonic doom so
fair enough and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the XS gamer
ooh the lord of combat sports king of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement ooh
beloved lord k how you doing sir you
know a blew my mind right now out in the
first ball on when I was doing a little
research on you my stuff I cool with
them I'm cool but then he said you were
just fancy green all over the floor
but spend the next hour talking about
Yahoo seems to go they need to get some
offensive linemen quickly so this
weekend I saw Ryan Garcia
it is another first-round knockout it
was a more like it was a beautiful it
was a beautiful knockout a couple of
seconds boom he did it was a macula um
what I've been playing y'all know I've
been playing there bleeding we saw the
promo on Twitter it was out of control I
felt it I just put it out there and it
is what it is um definitely playing a
Youngblood on this inside a game pass
right now you know I was playing my
destiny this crimson come today's I was
listening to the last word so make you
so much pressure got a a community to
what was going on through their
influence they've been training me up
here but I feel what Jason is saying and
I started waning off the wait a little
bit and the grind is back to that old
school destiny grind it feels like
you're back in college again you got
your notepad and all with your people
and you're making sure that you get this
running and it's back to that daily feel
so Jason I'm down if you if you want to
jump on that in there I also I just had
a kid and so I feel like my destiny
today in the first year of destiny and
the first couple years really I would do
raids we would do my group we would you
mind raid so like we would insist on
like sitting there not looking up
anything else's are cool we'd sit there
for hours just like marathoning and it
was some of the most fun I've ever had
in games but I feel like that time in my
life is just it's just over now that was
unspoken we'll do a blind rain until
we're at our friendships are about to
battle chest your friendship absolutely
yeah that's as people are not doing with
yeah absolutely keep it moving and of
course we have the gaming engine himself
this [ __ ] Robbie
lor Cognito spread that realness in the
realm of the ILP not telling which one
ahead but what you need to hear
not a lot of game playing this week out
of podcasting this week I want to give a
couple of shout outs real quick before
you started I want to shout out to my
brother Lord Ivonne test we had a
fantastic last word episode with Forbes
old Paul TAS see that it was really cool
he got a chance to kick it talk about on
everything the new looter shooters
that's coming out and compare comparison
that's the outriders divisions to lose
contact with warlords in New York and
anthem potentially you know with a RiRi
boot and I know I asked Jason some
questions about that later
but at home yeah so that's that that's
number one number two I want to give a
shout out to my brother my seasoned
gaming brothers Dan Rodriguez is Ainsley
Bowden from seasoned gaming had a
fantastic podcast with them pleased I
should be going up tomorrow I was a bald
man so please get those guys a shout out
when it goes up but we got all the
business to take care of
we got Jason - Ryan - Brown right now I
want to give a shout-out to you guys for
an intro that was 11 minutes long this
is the Lord's video game history
his Korean journey in journalism and of
course what led him to becoming the news
editor for the amazing Kotaku calm so
Lord Jason let's talk from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you a man that's all this is a phone all
right so my parents actually had a NES
Nintendo Entertainment System before I
was even born or like around the time I
was born I think I was born in the same
year it came out in 1987 and so so I
grew up with that fame constant so I was
just thinking cuz I just had a kid and
so we've been talking my wife and I have
been talking about like screen time like
when do we let her start watching things
and playing games and I was thinking
back to my childhood and like I don't
think the concept even existed of like
limited screens the Nintendo for just
like and I think they limited it more
when I got older like middle school like
elementary school but but like when I
was like two three four I was like
sitting there just playing through these
games and what I would do on the NES I
played through so many games on NES but
I had a very specific way of playing cuz
I'm sure some of you guys played those
games back in the day they were super
hard because it was like a carryover
from the arcade days where they would
inflate all the difficulty to get you to
keep paying those quarters right so I
would sit there with the NES and I would
play like the same sections of games
over and over again because I can get
any further so how would you like the
first like world of Super Mario Brothers
3 like I knew the entire flow but then I
would get to a point where I like
couldn't play anymore cuz I'm like four
years old like struggling to get a
certain things or like Final Fantasy the
first Final Fantasy was one of my like
favorite games of the time I would get
up to the marsh cave which is like one
of the first dungeons you get to and
then it was so hard to to make any more
progress from there that like never got
much further
I like brute force my way through like
how do yet but I can only take it to
certain points so like after after you
get to certain point you're just like
you know I'm 5 years old I can't do much
[Laughter]
I was gonna say the Super Nintendo is
really like my bread and butter it's
like like I said it was hard like the
blowing of cartridges shout-out to the
broad oh god salute the Super Nintendo
was like holy [ __ ] like these games are
amazing I remember first discovering
Final Fantasy 2 ak4 as we know it now
and that just blew my mind I was like oh
my god like video games gonna have these
stories that are like just as good as
stories that I read and then like
obviously Zelda Link to the Past blew my
mind and Super Mario World I would just
spend all this time I playing through
all those little games so yeah and then
from there just played as much as I
could after that I think I went ps1
because that was where Final Fantasy
moved to and I'm sure a lot of people
were like that was like now I'm not
getting an n64 I'm going over there you
go we thought about that we talked about
that as a huge turning point in
videogames I think that was like last
blast we don't at night talking at home
and I said that's that was when Sony was
extra aggressive and that showing them
the financials on what they would spend
making cartridges and paying a Nintendo
opposed to making the the compact disc
and paying them was a huge deciding fact
that plus the storage and the sound
quality and everything going forward to
cinematics everything was in line and
that was a real turning point in Sony's
souls
yeah yeah ok get it get it
shout at the Nintendo I'm pretty sure at
that time Final Fantasy was probably one
of the biggest games that was out and
Nintendo's like you take that and go we
don't care we don't care we don't want
to go see it was a deal had almost been
shot so real quickly and separate go
Lucas low to $2 super chat he says Jason
Schreyer thank you for your work in
gaming journalism so they giving it up
right now in the realm for Lord Jason so
you had that I went you went to
PlayStation which I myself I got I got a
backside you for a quick second um I
didn't hear any arm Sega consoles I
didn't hear any turnaround
there was no love for the Genesis no
love I didn't animus so my grandma had
at Genesis at her house I played that
occasionally and then I had a game gear
so I loved that thing
ok there was definitely some saying
about oh never into Sonic I still don't
understand it's a Mario where you're
like just like enjoying every moment
Sonic you're just like blurring through
everything like like the best way to
play Sonic is to not see the things that
you're thing
Sega was trying to figure out how can we
defend ourselves against a Nintendo
right and this blastmaster processing
what became oh a little word and how
fast they can move it on the screen and
I think once they found that out and you
know how Mario was plotting along its
so that was the the whole appeal the
signing I mean I went past levels and I
had to go back to see a level I
understand exactly yeah
but I did like some other Sega games I
liked phantasy star i have this game
called the landstalker that I love
actually it's just some cool things that
like are not selfish and fantastic music
a lot of those sing against I really
good music so yeah so I know some love
for Sega and then yeah and then I went
ps1 and then ps2 and then 3 Xbox 360
from there so that was yeah I think I
never had a regular Xbox what a big
clunky one he was growing some more I
was mostly into RPGs back in the day and
more later on so like when I got a 360 I
was like oh hey what's this GTA thing
I'm likely to gain more time and like
and and expanded more into other genres
and that's cool so yeah that's that's my
gaming my gaming is pretty extensive
computer games like point-and-click
adventures and stuff like that so that
you did the computer thing shoutout to
brat with the $20 super chat salute
lords
hi Jason appreciate the work you do in
journalism we got the game history yes I
want to get to of actually now the
journalistic side like what let's
discuss your passions as far as getting
into journalism and then what
specifically led you to Qatar's I know
you've had all you are at other outlets
if you did other things but let's start
that whole passion for journalism how
did that start
yeah well so it started I always wanted
to be a writer growing up and then I
discovered journalism in high school and
was on my high school paper as an editor
I would go to like like we would go to
like these seminars at Columbia every
year which is super cool we get to go to
Columbia University I was always into
journalism and then after I graduated
from college and I started doing some
freelance stuff and I always tell this
story because it's pretty funny I was
like I was right
for the bees like local websites and
local papers and stuff like that and
everything this dislike local government
board meeting and watch it where I grew
up if he wasn't like shouts out to
Westchester to build it
yeah well so I was I was up there and
I'm sitting in this room full of like
these old dudes who are like like zoning
regulations and they're like can we can
we build this fence 20 feet or 15 feet
and like this is literally in our year
like I'm sitting there like like pen and
paper in hand be like this is what I've
to write a revelation there is like I
want to write about something more
interesting than this and so I thought
and I said I'm like did some research I
was like you know what why don't I try I
love games I I had written like a couple
were freely like not freelance review
unpaid reviews for like a man's eye back
in the day back in back in college and
so I was like why don't I try doing this
and like so I went and pitch myself and
started like getting freelance deals
which was really awesome and then I
wound up applying for this gig at Wired
under Chris Nolan over 100 and Kohler
hired me and that was kind of my first
big break and then from there I started
doing work for them and like other feel
that stuff and then wound up getting an
email from Stephen too till oh no that
12 Steve in 2011 it was like the end or
2011 he sent me an email and then we got
a drink and he was like look I'm gonna
be taking over Kotaku love come aboard
and it's like alright I'm in and I've
been there for eight years now so a
little bit Mendes work over there
awesome that we got a chance to beat
also lost even to Tello as well so
that's that's a cool story coming around
guy and getting into journalism
yeah well it's funny cuz we ran into
each other in the street we had just ran
into D just like yes we weren't walking
together and then you guys came up just
because the you you joined our random
encounter yeah it was like the thing
that happens at e3 that's the beauty of
e3 shout out a big shout out to a
downtown LA gridlock
[Laughter]
we do be raining in the random people
yeah hey you know it's warm up you know
what's funny though before we met them
it was like a really really large bottle
of wrap with a Ricard asked the question
I'm coming to the question anyway now we
got the journalism asthma God decide
I'll beat I want to actually I
completely understand but as far as your
journey but I want to focus on game
journalism right now I think this was
breakfast alluding to just a state of it
you're a pagan of it in 2020 we know
that there's you know if you guys around
and then I want to use it a term that
you coined the YouTube provocateur so I
want to talk about just a state of that
and then like basically can these things
both coexist and just like just what
you're feeling on a state of game
journalism right now yeah well of course
they can coexist they haven't coexisted
for years now and and people are still
moving on keeping on keeping on
and YouTube has some great stuff I
should say it's it's there's certainly a
lot of rage punditry and language
headlines man what's what's with the
YouTube like thumbnail that's always
like someone going like this Phil
Spencer dead
[Laughter]
got the provocateur talk that we do it
[Music]
but ya know it's it's man I I was
actually thinking about that cuz I saw a
bunch of one of the things one of the
reasons you mentioned anthem before yeah
one of the reasons that actually a
couple of months ago we broke the news
that anthem was getting this renewal 2.0
one of the reasons we ran that story is
because I kept seeing headlines and
YouTube thumbnails that were like anthem
is dead oh my god anthem is dead
and I want to be like no they're just
being quiet while they were gonna sing
anyway so a state of journalism I mean
it is what it is like I wish there was
more money in it I think that's the
biggest problem is that there isn't a
ton of money in it there are only so
many like big gaming sites there and
like less than a dozen big gaming sites
these days that actually like pay their
writers and can keep people employed
full time with benefits and stuff like
that I'm super lucky to be part of one
of those sites and yeah I mean it's it
it's it seems to be it seems like people
are thriving it seems like some of these
sites are able to make money I mean the
media landscape in general is full of
all sorts of [ __ ] and anyone who's
been following the saga Ed's been knows
about my own companies just like
struggles but but in general it's been
cool to see I mean I think games
journalism in general has come a long
way since I started and especially since
like the 90s yeah
eighties days there's been so much more
talk about like serious issues in the
games industry and crunch and labor and
just to see even the fact that like me
so many more people are talking about
this stuff these days as opposed to just
like what's the latest screenshot of the
next big game that's coming and that's
stuff I mean that definitely has its
place and there's nothing wrong with
like being excited and like generating
hype and talking about games that are
moving out but like it's important to
also talk about the labor side and then
the troubles love the games industry and
I'm really glad to see that journalism
game journalism is like moving in that
direction no doubt real quick things
funny
kognito talk about something like oh you
know some something happened in a
company selling left he's like man we'll
probably never find out man because even
one of us always say almost the exact
same time I guess we'll have to wait to
Jason we gotta blow that story up real
quick the day I said you know what know
that provocateur title yeah I think I
fall in line I said you know what he's
saying is definitely true to be honest
with you um I look at it as actors and
hip-hop artists right so you have these
trained actors that go to Juilliard and
do all this great stuff and they learn
their way up and then you have these
hip-hop artists that come in and get a
movie role you'll sir are really
technically not an actor if this is the
case so it would be a little name for
them but as far as provocateur year
because I can always fall back on if I
put out an article if I don't put out
articles but if I say something I go we
just say look I'm not a journalist
so basically accountability -
accountability and I feel like a
journalist is hold to a higher standard
tree like giving your thoughts and stuff
there's I have nothing against that it's
more that like the accountability part
that you mentioned is important you'd
like to use your comparison it's like
like some of the youtubers that I've
seen in some of the videos I've seen
specifically are like the equivalent of
like if the hip-hop hip-hop singer on
set like goes around and starts shoving
[Laughter]
but that's it I mean I think there is
plenty of room and in fact I think it's
really healthy to have like people who
are just like giving their opinions to
an audience especially people who are
reaching audiences that like I said like
otaku who might not reach I feel like
it's important to have like what the the
punditry and the analysis and the
criticism for everybody have the
entertainment for everybody like I I'm
not against that at all similarly agree
him all the way through like I was like
I don't even know why this is
controversial we go get there right now
oh shut up to gay before it take you to
tell us which I've morning Lord tastes
to another game get great podcast so
let's get to the controversy real quick
because that braaap has been asking and
everyone's been asking so it reference
to you know there's a term that's going
on right now especially what a lot of
gamers it's the media bias term right
and it's a hot topic you don't when when
you know an article comes out and people
feel you know what
they're attacking my but this this
plaque this artists site has a
reputation for attacking you know that's
what they feel a specific you know
platform all the time you know damn it
they always attacking my xbox or damn it
switch get that gets the love and you
know so like I wouldn't bring that out
to you like do you think first of the
magical question do you think bias
exists it gravy journalism and then
number two you know in your you
personally would obviously we've seen
your Twitter we know we know how it goes
down your block game is legit but I just
want it I want to talk about just in
general like how do you guys handle that
you know when you have to deal with that
aspect of gamers saying you know hey you
know I don't like what you've said about
such a such so a couple things first of
all to an earlier point I think that I
just saw uncut gems and Kevin Garnett is
incredible that movie so like sometimes
come in and be like and just like kill
it so I just had that random outsider
media bias a medium s definitely exists
Oh mega bub wrap is gonna lose his mind
right now could you please repeat that
okay wait so now there's gonna be
YouTube thumbnails to make a do YouTube
thumbnail right now Jason and it's gonna
be like yeah I'm just waiting I just
want to see I like to see the YouTube
faces like the face and it's usually
it's usually some like white dude in
their 20s like some ridiculous like that
so wait so let me let me finish sorry
face media bias exists in the sense that
every single person like brings their
own opinions of thoughts and analysis
and ideas to anything they write like
there's no such thing as objective
journalism you're talking about console
war bias every single journalist I've
talked to myself included thinks that's
the most asinine thing is a console wars
are possibly the dumbest and most
annoying thing about gamers there's
nothing more annoying to me and it's
especially Xbox fans who got but but
Sony fans also oh good intended fans I
think because I rave about the swish so
much antenna fans don't bother me
[Laughter]
so with Sony fans it was when I reported
that horizon zero dawn is coming to PC
the Sony fans like kept going after me
and that was a whole mess Xbox fans
anytime I criticize the Xbox for any
reason they all go after me so it turns
into this thing we're like I think that
they're all just dumbest [ __ ] because I
think anyway anyone who has brand
loyalty to a console is just playing
themselves it's just thank you you are a
soldier for this billion bazillion
dollar company that you are doing free
brands like management for your just
like helping the people in house exactly
like you are just like a peon you have
no thought of you're like I just don't
understand it I cannot understand at all
just this idea of like fanboy ISM and I
mean I do understand tribalism because
our Sports grin like hey I'm voting for
your team and I can see how that would
transfer on to gaming but like to create
this world where you think journalists
are biased against your favorite console
music they gave crackdown 3 a 5 out of
10 or they give days gone a 6 out of 10
or whatever the [ __ ] like be existing in
that world is not existing in reality
like hey I can promise you that well I
guess I can't promise this but as far as
I can tell and I've had a lot of
interactions with a whole lot of
journalists for every single gaming site
many of them are my friends and
colleagues and I don't love all of them
but the people that but but everybody
that I've talked to you about this stuff
right like thinks this is acid
like nobody has any interest in that
it's more when it comes to biases it's
more like oh I grew up playing this RPG
so I'm into I have a bias towards
finally talking about that you know I
review a Final Fantasy I actually wrote
a review of Final Fantasy 15 for Kotaku
a few years ago and if you read that I
actually wrote it in a way that makes it
clear that I am like a huge Final
Fantasy and good I think it's helpful to
acknowledge that way topping that game
but like the the console warfare thing
that is just like this imaginary battle
and the heads of these people on Twitter
who just have no no lives they spent all
day how many people on that blockless
fleet I was actually thinking about this
the other day
let me check I'll bring it up for you
right now clear yeah I only block people
well I bought people for a few reasons I
feel like I blocked the brand so I like
put ads in my Twitter feed I bought it
yeah I bought people if they annoy me if
they are gamergaters
I definitely block them okay if they
tweet at me nasty things okay if a
really if they annoy me I have no that's
my time I'm not nobody when it comes to
someone's personal social media like
that is your thing like you can block
everyone you see that's still your
social media started blocking people do
you feel like it's a confirmation bias
type of thing like if you feel
somebody's a negative towards something
you start producing that type of energy
you start seeing that and you only queue
on to all the bad reviews and not all
the good reviews because I believe it's
just as many bad reviews or something
comes out there's just as many good
reviews but the fact that you're just
looking to queue on the bad reviews I
think that brings out the confirmation
bias and things opposed to when they say
media bias because in this generation
now I think a lot of people felt that
Microsoft wasn't giving a fee
shake I believe you make your own
destiny right so I believe the mistakes
made in the prior administration if it's
like these guys were so cute on to the
negative they weren't receiving the
positive and I don't think there's a
media bias per se but I believe that
there's a confirmation bias when it goes
into people's mind it's like when you
purchase a car and you start to see your
car more it's just you're confirming it
and you're more aware of it that's all I
believe that is I don't believe that
there's an actual media bias I believe
that there's more of a confirmation bias
okay yeah well people who love stories
they love narratives and like the
narrative this past generation has been
like Microsoft flopping failing like
Sony destroying them ergun Sony and then
Microsoft turning things around so in
that sense I think boy you see now as a
lot of journalists being like whoa look
how Microsoft is like linking Hubbard
and turn things around and look at all
the cool things they're doing with the
xbox game pass which you guys are
talking about earlier which is amazing
for anyone who plays games mm-hm and
look at how they're positioned for all
this cool stuff in next-gen like the way
that they're approaching their hardware
there's a lot of interesting stuff there
and I think that people in general like
human beings love really easy stories
and they love narratives and that in
itself yeah like you said that that
helps create the confirmation bias and
that for sure
contributes to you like the way that
people in might feel like people are
piling on really but that is something
to see like someone isn't coming on like
a journalist isn't coming to work every
day and be like you know what
we got super dollar super chat from brat
preach Jason no console war by sexists
okay we're gonna go ahead straight to
the next one
whoa ponies take heat to Lord Lord and
then G I got G mark lowest toda so which
I get Gears of Ultimate Edition too much
a button okay I don't know where that's
going Jason is there such thing as a
control bleak with embargo dates
question for Jason I control the leak
like I guess I guess like like they
don't they intend it but they wanted to
look like a listen I've never heard of
any let me get gene that's my boy that's
lords of gaming dot Nets
alrighty he'll be will be our packs ten
down super chat Jason thanks for coming
on thoughts on the timeline for new
consoles and the rumors of chip issues
will your new book be a launch title
just kidding
Jake what I keep wondering is how
coronavirus is gonna effective in China
that that is what concerns me and I
wonder what they're gonna have to do if
that continues chip fish news I don't
know I haven't heard anything about chip
chip manufacturing issues maybe there's
some new rumor that I haven't I mean the
past four weeks because I've been like
marathoning on my book I haven't paid
super close attention every single game
story but um but yeah I haven't heard
anything like that there would be going
in on that today really it'd be really
tough if like coronavirus or something
else forced yessir of them to get out of
this fog so just I do have a question
like let's say that the coronavirus
forces one to leave the holiday but not
the other you think that would be
dramatically effective for the other yes
a hundred percent oh not the Ryan Landis
which I chasing what he said like this
is a whodunit what really happened to
show and late in the body Zack
[Laughter]
we gotta move over just gotta live it in
time with these doubts a great sight but
I had to get that anything that the fans
did well wanted that so let's get to the
bait of it which is a blood sweat and
pixels man and that is the outstanding
piece of work that you did a gem of
investigative reporting you're welcome I
don't read much but I read that yeah and
how Cal videogames are made especially
like behind the scenes you know one
aspect of game development a lot of
gamers you know we we really don't have
no clue about what's going on I'll be
the first but I was part of that so it
was really cool to see you kind of lift
that veil right and and show what was
going on with development a lot of our
beloved games yet witcher 3 yet destiny
in there you know i'm saying so many
good games so i want to ask about the
creative process about that creating
that as far as inspiring the book and
then what are some of the hardest
aspects of light of that investigative
report like getting those schools
getting these people to maybe a dominant
I don't honestly talk to you and like
though the risk involved like break that
whole process down sure um one more
thing I just have this other random
thought I was robbed I I actually think
something that really affects bias more
than anything else is like how crazy
fans are gonna react and this is
something that I hear about a lot from
reviewers and that is like there used to
be and maybe there still is this this
idea that like reviewers are bribed by
big corporations and PR they're worried
about PR people or whatever else that
doesn't happen if it does happen it's
reported if it does happen someone send
me a tip so I can write about it but
what does happen is that people are
worried about how readers will react and
that has led to people giving a little
bit higher CJC
I mean this is not on the reviewers like
this is not the fault of the reviewer
this is because they're [ __ ] crazy
fans and like and I think that if
anything people will overcorrect because
of like crazy Xbox fanboys or crazy pony
fanboys they're plenty on both sides
going after them
and like overcorrect by like not wanting
to say something not want me to write
something or not wanting to to score
something I got a I got a follow I gotta
follow hold or I gotta ask this so this
is this is you just drop the ball now my
question is do you think this is more so
in line with the rise of the Metacritic
error because a lot of gamers now that
Metacritic is like the Holy Grail that's
the Bible if that game is the 90
something medically oh Lord
my my champion is better than your
champion right so do you think this all
kind of plays into is it cyclical yeah I
actually wrote a piece of few years ago
about all the problems and then a critic
and all the all the ways that publishers
like manipulate it and all the ways that
it's worth reading you should check it
out because I just Google could talk
about it
so yeah and I think that anything that
like gamma Phi's quality like anything
that tries to quantify the the level of
a game the amount of fun in a game or
whatever else is gonna be poisonous to
discourse and just like gonna gonna make
people like inflame people and rage
people more because not only you enter
this this you combine that with the
tribalism and it's like oh look Sony had
more top rated movie they go to me
crackdown 3 whatever yes so that I think
is is just like it's all contributing
it's all this just like Giants do of
like toxic behavior and shittiness on
the Internet let's get all these super
[Music]
JD gaming with the $10 stupid chat bias
exists in everything whether it's in a
favorite sports team or brand name jeans
people are wired to categorize things
and designate them good or bad which
leads to bias key is to admit that bias
shot the elemental Peele final super
chat who will bend the knee when we all
find out
Sony rush to launch or PM 5 oh my god
super Jeff from clouds Jason what was
your favorite point and click game
oh man back in the day monkey islands
here's a really funny one
I got a studio
was Jason blink twice as Shawn Leighton
is that all right that out - will my
heard Mike oh my god will me
$99 super 200 are super shot morning
lords and and I have to agree the gaming
community Kim can be extremely toxic No
- I have to slow-mo backslap brat
podcast Jason how many credible sources
do you need to hear the same info from
before you go public with the info
thanks for the work you do that's a good
question it depends it depends on who
the sources are it depends what kind of
sources they are if it's like someone
who has first-hand knowledge versus
someone who has secondhand knowledge and
what position they're in it depends what
the info is if it's something like you
mungus I might want to wait for as many
people as possible so it really depends
are so like Oh fair there's no cut and
dry answer ideally at least to be on
mission do you do kind of how do you
determine what to sit on and what not to
sit on like in terms of how you view the
information is coming out right what's
more important what could you sort of
let let it you know whatever the
publisher whatever talk about themselves
how do you sort of determine what you
come out with and what you don't
yeah this is something that I like
wrestle with all the time still because
it's something I don't have a clear
answer to the answer is the the actual
answer is on a case-by-case basis like I
talked to my editor Steven and we figure
it out the like I really don't know
because I give a lot of thought to like
is this going to cause unnecessary pain
to anybody is this going to arm people
is gonna like like so many times I hear
from game developers who like take this
stuff seriously and like feel really
shitty when their announcement is leaked
for one reason or another so I give that
consideration to often times I mean the
stories I prefer doing are stories that
are like you won't find out about this
anyway as oppose you this is gonna be
announced in a few months or francs or
whatever yeah but those stories are so
important just because it's important to
get info out there that's my job is to
report information so it really depends
and like I I could talk a lot about this
because I wrestle with this a lot but I
wanna know just real quick cuz we got to
get the topics going we gotta get your
thing is just real quickly your thing is
not to be first just to be
correct and so your mind is clear when
you put out your pieces well both first
and correct is ideal funny story when I
first started Kentucky it was like
February 20 2012 I was listening to an
ubisoft earnings call and you know how
Yves gilma the the CEO and very thick
French accent yeah so yeah he said he
said something like the new Assassin's
Creed will be coming out on November so
TVs so teeth so teeth it was said like
that right I was like oh xxx and then it
turned out to be 13 there's something
like that and I said to my boss I was
like oh my god like I just started right
so like I don't know what I'm doing I'm
like man how do you like are how are you
both quick and accurate and he looks at
me and he's like you better be [ __ ]
both you have to be both fast and
accurate because that's the job that's
the job of journalist oh it's hard but
that's why like you I mean that's that's
why you get the the public position and
I see you get so yeah to answer your
question I mean both is really important
yeah yeah I feel as a journalist you
wrestle with stuff so yeah so we gotta
move like stuff that won't be that'll be
announced like that I hear about I'm
like trying to weigh over whether I want
to report it now yeah usually I know
it's accurate whether I want to record
it now and like spoil the announcement
and potentially like really make some
people mad make some people who work in
games and like what feel special about
their game and don't want it revealed
through a coach oculi that's the sort of
thing that I'm talking about and that's
so good I think about all the time well
you asked my second part in reference to
the investigative end so we got that
that part yeah what iteration yeah Plus
was the inspiration like what made you
say okay I want to put these stories
together for the Yogi's these games a
specific game yeah so it's a funny story
so in 2014 it all starts with destiny a
lot of my career so 2014 destiny comes
out we don't play it it's clearly a mess
when it launched it's clear like this
story it's even like even today looking
back at it it's so funny like
like characters just pop up and
disappear
clearly it feels like this this just
like monta like hotpot hodgepodge like
like when you you haven't gone in the
grocery store in the while and you're
like what's in my fridge that I can mix
together to like make some dinner
tonight and so you're like all right I
got mustard and kale and some oh I think
some pork over here and you're just like
all right what can I do with all this
that's that's the Destiny sword is like
and it did not taste good so so I was
like I kept asking how did this happen
like something must have happened here
right and so over time I started finding
out more and more whenever any a story
in the fall of 2015 that was about how
destiny story was rebooted and all the
stuff that happened behind the scenes to
make destiny um and after that I got an
email from this guy Charlie who is now
my Asian it was like hey like we could
turn this into a book and so we started
talking we put together this proposal
that was like what if it was a book
collection of stories like this and so
we shot that around a book publishers
got a couple bites and wound up signing
a deal in 2016 and then I went off and
started doing on the reporting I'm like
talking to people and and getting the
stories together when it comes to stuff
like writing that book and stories was
it particularly hard to get that info
from some of these publishers and
developers some of them so what happened
with the first book was I reached out to
a bunch of different publishers like for
because their student types of stories
right there's the official story that's
like PR sanctioned and like people are
on the record and stuff and then there's
the unofficial story where you go around
and you talk to people and you try to
get them to talk to you ideally using
their name but if necessary anonymously
you can try to get them to talk to you
and tell you the real story about right
so the book is a mix of both some of
them were me going to like Naughty Dog
and talking to the Uncharted for people
or like going to obsidian it's on the
pillars of eternity people and then some
of the stories were me tracking on my
own people who worked on Halo Wars or
I'm destiny on Star Wars 1313 right so
it's like a good mix of of that stuff
and there are actually some stories that
I wanted to do but couldn't because the
publishers know or like it's in America
the one that I really wanted to do and
still would love it it's Madden because
what
an annual release cycle is super super
crazy like crazy amount of overtime and
like they they essentially have like
nine months to make each game because
yeah like right before you release it
right after your knees right oh so they
can't actually do anything substantial
with that and so I find that super
fascinating but sadly they didn't want
to participate and haven't been able to
do that yet maybe one day hopefully one
no doubt real quick I'm never gonna want
to participate man to give the super
chest out of JD gamer Jason what do you
think about crack that I think of time
for that but yes therein will be hood
timestamp 20 I switch that timestamp you
super chat Jason does not deny the
PlayStation 5 will be solar-powered
laughs I love all right so we got I do
have one question
sue you know the publishers you know
we're talking about you know the book
and getting the info from your personal
experience what would you say is the
easiest like big publisher to work with
[Laughter]
these beloved by with it they love this
investigative them have like their
quirks right so like Nintendo for
example Nintendo is super good about
sending us early copies of games like
really early right they'll send out
games like sometimes three four weeks in
advance but they're much more like
tight-lipped when it comes to like
getting interviews about things or like
like wanting to go dive into things and
like to special features on them and
stuff like that so everyone has kind of
like their their pros and cons when it
comes to the way that they interacted
these are like you can review our stuff
and give a publicity you ain't talking
to none of us over here they want their
interviews to be tied to current product
so they like don't want to do stuff on
like older games or like other
interesting profiles or stuff like that
they just want to be like all right time
to sell the new Animal Crossing we want
to do interview that's so I don't you
got your money already so I just want
you to buy the new stuff very different
than yeah a lot of cultural reasons for
like like they're very quiet and a lot
of ways and the user
than tight-lipped about a lot of things
okay real quick we move over the last
two days of reference to that was
obvious just want to ask for me
personally the last name is nesting
question obviously tremendous blah
information on that now in this current
destiny world with Bungie on their own
you know post Activision and then we
know they've lost high Moon Studios of
our current vision that helped out do
you think this pushes back destiny three
or do you know do you think that's III
still on on track with the current set
up and then I want to get into anthem I
think destiny I think they've actually
made it clear that they see destiny too
is their future for at least the next
few years and I think they made that
clear last year when they did their
whole thing like right before e3 when
they did their big live stream and Smith
and Mark news really came out and they
were like this is gonna be a consistent
like persistent evolving world by the
love whatever buzz words they use I
think they're trying to keep destiny to
going for a long time I think there is
their plan and I know they're doing
other games too you know how many it's
probably either six or seven hundred
people of Bungie these days between
destiny twos constant stream of updates
and some of the other games they're
working on
who knows if they even have the
bandwidth for like making a totally new
destiny 3 so yeah it's a it's a tricky
one but I think at least for the next
couple of years I think destiny 2 is
gonna be just like constantly cycled in
and out a new stuff gotcha anthem
question because again tremendous
investigative reporting I mean you broke
some stuff at the King provocateur but I
mean I wanna I want to touch on that
Jason man I mean you you really killed
it and we had no idea what was going on
behind the scenes so I wanna I want to
ask you in reference to the anthem
obviously we know the rumblings that
it's you know they're trying to make a
comeback then they're not gonna abandon
the game but there's there's a point of
contention about some of the stuff that
your contention but there's there's some
some questions we have which is in
reference to the difficulty of the
Frostbite engine right the climate there
as far as leadership and you know and
your reports saying that they would take
so long just to make a decision and and
then we're hearing things now from the
Lee right
Djuka pre-compression stating that it
was so corporate and he's making kind of
like so with all this information like
based on what she wrote and what you
reported you know who do you blame or do
you do you feel it's Bioware true they
were the one that's currently exist not
the one that we know from back in the
day they think they were just
misdirection or was it frostbite is so
difficult and EA just do this in their
hand and they just should have just
fought back maybe push back kind of like
I respawn with Vince and purlins like no
we're using unreal we're not doing that
so what what's your thought process on
this um well I mean I think that it's
clear and the piece that I were last
year that it's Bioware made this game
and EA was not coming in and being like
you guys have to make it that's the
clone the way that a lot of people
thought they were it was more like I
were saying hey this is what we wanted
to and by his leadership kind of unable
to step up and fill the void that Casey
Hudson left I parted and then not all
sorts of problems that I mentioned their
first plate is certainly a huge problem
for now we're people that would not be a
problem without EA but I think I also
think that a lot of this is like it's
very difficult to kind of distinguish
the two companies after a certain point
and it's very difficult to be like well
this this company is the problem and not
this company this company because so
many people are just constantly moving
in and out and where that EA operates is
that like they'll have people from all
their Studios working on all their
different games right so like right now
they're people in EA Vancouver working
on anthem on the new it and they're
people in a bio we're working on like
dice stuff or like other like they have
people or more because they have they
only have certain number of engineers
across the company right and some of
those people have to be like on call for
different games based on what's needed
do you think that makes all of their
employees more diverse if they're always
working on different projects like that
I don't know I think it depends on the
employee it's events like what type of
person you want to you you are and if
you like doing that sort of thing but
I'm making wider is that like the way
that I don't know if you guys have ever
worked for a company that then got
acquired by someone else they're like
that taking over someone a little fool
so
like the way the corporate culture works
is it's a very gradual subtle thing yes
I'm like suddenly you'll go into the
cafeteria and like the posters won't be
on the yep and someone suddenly like
this one person relied on in HR like no
longer works there yep
so like that's the type of thing that
happens when ei acquires a studio and I
think II ain't very good at like being
hands-off almost to a negative extent
because they might have letting
developers with that they acquire just
kind of do what what they wanted to you
but also it's hard to deny and it's hard
to get away from that like gravitational
of like the corporate culture of the
company so yeah I think then that often
times like we like I said before we like
stories we like narrative scene is
especially so it's hard to kind of
imagine it's hard to even fathom the
nuances that often go into this sort of
thing but it's a lot a lot of that is
important because people are what makes
these games great are the people and
like if you look at the credits for some
of these games you'll see that like well
how much of Bioware is even still around
these days how much it's like what is bi
or even mean today and I think that's
some of the stuff the true core portion
was alluding to right a lot of its just
the way that these things can change
yeah yeah it's easy for us to like put
all this power into a brand without like
the specific people in very short anthem
is a mess because of a lot of so it's a
combination of both the combination see
that was the journalistic destiny and
the division I never thought there would
be a middle ground that somebody would
gravitate to because it's like picking a
school is you are already like tribalism
you are already in one camp you already
in another camp split three ways yeah
well if it would be interesting to see
if it was good and if it comes back and
it's like anthem 2.0 and it's actually
really good it'll be interesting to see
if they think I got a shot with Casey
back just black my last one yeah but
they got a shot
I think Casey Casey's current role as
studio head so I don't think he has
hands on in the
he's more of the corporate oversight
type person like liaison hang with VA
and stuff like that I I do think they
have a shot just because they have a lot
of people and bots in austin who worked
on Star Wars The Old Republic who are
talented people who are now working on
this thing and who knows I mean I there
are a lot of different ways this could
go but I think Casey
Casey's involvement now is more from
like an overall strategic was directing
the game so we do have a super net that
is question for you yeah we got a fight
our cloak 901 I definitely put your name
I apologize Jason do you think the
remembered first party gains from Sony
going to PC is good for gaming I think
it is question I think it tremendous for
gaming really they got bad at you know
world is like no consoles anymore
because they're all like open garden pcs
we've kind of we become a customer this
clothes garden ecosystem we like the
compos all have their exclusives and you
only make games for sister consoles and
if you think about if you like really
step back and think about it that is so
bad for the customer as opposed to a
world where it was like like imagine if
you could only play your sony blu rays
on your sony blu-ray players on the
lions let's just get to it oh I love
that philosophy for me I don't
understand why they're still doing an
Xbox series X instead of an Xbox that is
that runs steam and is open garden and
lets you play anything that's let's get
to it Jason because you really
translated that into a full look alright
so next year cash of course was
authorized right in the common in 2020
we got two differing approaches right we
got Microsoft you know obviously we had
the the video game awards revealed the
series X the hell-blade you know and as
King jokingly calls them filled out -
Maximus Spencer Xbox oh yes yes Xbox
only begotten Son
with very it's very aggressive and we
know they're very aggressive with the
philosophy of game past versus so duties
seem to be taking more of a measured
patient approach the playstation 5 and
as far as the reveal but we do know that
they're doing exclusives to PS 5 only as
opposed to the microsoft philosophy
where for the first two years you know
that they're gonna be kind of cross
generational throughout cut a bit so 3
is totally different it's like more of
like a phone thing or it'll get like yes
certain isolate generations of like
obsolete like right yeah but go ahead
literally that was it my question so
just what's your feeling on both
approaches now coming into this gin like
where are you at with both sides yeah I
mean like I said I'm very anti exclusive
in general like I think everything
should be on everything so it would
thrill me if like Sony made it so I
could play PC I wanna open anarchists
but that's what I want and I think we
are headed towards that way I think
Microsoft is really forward thinking in
terms of like creating an ecosystem for
Xbox and getting everyone on Xbox game
paths which is like such a good value
right now that it's ridiculous I think I
treated this a couple months ago and
Bethesda announced their fallout like a
subscription thing for fame for like
less than this subscription you could
get an Xbox game pass with the outer
worlds and fallout 4 and like Fallout
New Vegas I don't know fall before being
assembly so like why would anyone do
this but anyway my point is that that
like offers a ton of value to anybody I
am a little worried that like we're
gonna get to this world sort of like
we're headed in TV where there
bazillion subscriptions and like
suddenly everybody's yeah we're heading
hitting this confluence of too many and
it's oversaturated but I think that's
the future that I would like to see is
what Xbox is doing as opposed to Sony's
old-school like we're gonna make games
for PlayStation thank my dad with
horizon as I reported a couple of weeks
ago going to PC I think it'll be
interesting to see if that's like a
one-off thing question and then forget
about it or if they bring more games to
BC I wouldn't be surprised if they bring
more games to PC after that we shall see
okay philosophy I believe it's a new
Sony I don't believe it's the same old
Sony did doing some of the same old
methods but trying to do new methods and
if they do make money with with horizon
zero dawn and I think that opens the
floodgates to bring over all the games
like god of war games like Spider Man
let's let's get old money and turn it
into new money and then going forward
you might see a date and date
I don't know but do you think date and
date might happen if they are hugely
successful in bringing these older irps
over could be I honestly have no idea I
have no idea what they're thinking I'm
no idea what I mean really what they're
thinking right now is seems pretty
baffling like the fact that they've
revealed the PlayStation 5 through to I
read articles strange to me um so
bizarre like such a bizarre way of doing
things especially because people love
the whole like stage show like
presentation I remember I mean I people
freaked out of the PlayStation meeting
in February of 2013 and they not fetus
or like people love that [ __ ] so yeah I
would think that they would want to
recreate that surface but who even knows
what these days clearly a lot of
executives shuffling and shakeups and
people moving around
Herman hulls from guerilla games just
took over as the head of places
worldwide studios so that's definitely
gonna change some things and make some
things it'll lead to a lot of
interesting changes I'm sure for them
yeah I have no yeah and the and the and
the active users think now they're
saying now they've pretty much mirroring
what Xbox trusted to say where they're
saying is she just saying that's the new
metric that they're judging console as
opposed to you know a lot of the fanboys
saying you know that costs hardware is
did the facto metric and they're saying
no I'll be as a philosophy chaser do you
also see things I'm not gonna call them
what kidding cause what do you see them
shifting on on on their philosophies
yeah I mean could be I I honestly have
no idea I I don't know Jim Ryan at all
and I don't really know anything about
the way that he thinks in the way that
his strategy is gonna unfold but I am
very curious and I would like to see
them do something that's like like more
of a focus on PlayStation now and like
getting getting more of the if the
ecosystem rather than the platform I
think that's the smart approach and I
think it's what people want I don't
think people want to be tied to two
consoles anymore one thing one Tibbett I
will share one thing that I have done
yes and this is like mirror's inquired
stuff so it's not like a huge scoop
they've hinted it the sort of thing
before but I think one of the things
they're going for is like right now you
open up your ps4 like you you turn on
your ps4 and if you can find the tiny
little power thing like yeah we're
searching for the power I'll do the same
and then you open up the game it takes a
couple minutes for the ps4 to load you
open up a game it has to download a
patch it takes another 20 minutes then
you load up the game it takes forever to
load 10 minutes by the time you got into
the game you're out of time and like you
have to go put your kid to sleep or
something right good so I think what
they're going for is cutting all that
down and making their PS v accessible to
them to to the extent that Netflix is
accessible and I think one of the other
things I've heard is that like in
presentations to developers they're like
think of like we want to do what Netflix
says where you can just like turn this
on like pick where you want to be at a
certain point like if you just want to
play multiplayer call of duty you just
download the multiplayer part yeah like
who knows how much of this will actually
come to fruition and one one of the
reasons I'm hesitant to share a lot of
what I hear about like recruits of next
gen consoles change high in the sky yeah
well like with the Xbox one for example
is a bit of a tension let's go there
there producers used to go around with
these flashcards that would be like like
cloud and like SmartGlass we're going
connect and obviously all that changed
drastically right so things change very
very quickly and very very drastically
but anyway with Sony I think that's part
of their whole big grand vision is like
play games and as easy a forum as
possible so that you're not tempted to
just like say [ __ ] it and switch to
Netflix so much easier to do it I'm also
so they can reach more and more people
who like what arm only play games
alright last question is that kind of
sense because that's a huge deterrent
for me that's why I turn it on and I see
all these updates I got to do when I'm
looking someplace else last question cuz
we're actively at the Bark on so crunch
culture I know yep you're reporting on
this you have some very strong feelings
about it obviously you know the
situation at Rockstar and things of that
nature and you shining a light a lot on
these things so and I know how you feel
about unions and things that nature so I
just want to say like you know why is it
so important to you
and then the second thing is also do you
ever think you know will ever get to a
point of like maybe a games you know
Union for these developers and stuff
like that and the flip side which is
sometimes an argument which is a lot of
people say well hey no one's got a gun
to your head and make you you know
developer a you know you could just you
know say it kind of thing so that's like
the comic where it's like someone a
peasant being like society should be
improved like no you you don't have to
be like look at that comic first let's
say to answer on my wife Chris Walker I
don't shut off my camera okay
so to answer your second question I do
think a union is gonna happen oh wow
question of when not if like we're
getting to the point the last that I saw
was some survey that was like fifty
forty four percent of survey developers
want to unionize Wow so that is
humongous and I think that's just gonna
keep growing as more and more people
like talk about it and get educated and
like what a union can do
because it's not really it's having been
through the wringer and like actually
been part of a company that is unionized
and like heard all the pros and cons
it's not exactly what I thought it was
when I first started off so I do think
it's gonna happen as more and more
people get educated and talk about what
a union can do for their companies and
their like traits right
so as for crunch culture and why I care
about it I actually think it's really
important and this is something I've
tried to make clear I think it's really
important to not decouple crunch from a
lot of the other issues in video games
going right because a lot of people work
ridiculous as my wife is a lawyer she
works crazy hours right now what kind of
makes gaming stand out in a lot of ways
is that it's not just crunch it's also
pretty low pay and volatility which is
yes okay I'm working on right now is
it's about these constant layoffs that
you see whenever a company's of Vienna
their production cycle and then you
always hear like last year with Bobby
Kotick being like Activision Blizzard is
in the best shape ever as 800 people are
being laid off this wealth disparity its
sexism and racism which are like as big
as the video game in in the video game
industry as they are in the video game
community and like all these other
problems plenty of other things that I'm
not bringing up right now I'm stresses
of like management and with I were one
of the things I heard from a lot of
those people is that the stress that
came up for them was not even the crunch
as much as like the fact that like they
knew that what they were working on
might not be relevant or might not be
good or like could be ripped apart and
torn up I've been writing about one of
the the chapters in my new book is
actually about irrational and BioShock
Infinite and that was a stressful
project not just because a crunch she
was a nice act of a crunch
people not just because of crunch but
because ken Levine the creative director
about shotguns and it would be
constantly rewriting and changing things
and iterating and just like ripping
things apart and throwing out people's
hard work and that made for a better
game ultimately or at least that's what
they saw is maybe making for a better
game because it's a necessary part of
the creative process but like it also is
extremely stressful even if you are
living this dream life I get to make
video games for a living it just winds
up like all these stresses compound so
it's not just crunch is the point that
I'm trying to go like we all work I've
been working like 16-hour days for the
best few weeks trying to finish this
book we all we've all had to work long
hours that combined with everything else
that just makes things really terrible
okay sometimes often times people don't
get paid for the crutch because they're
on salary so like real quick just to cut
time to the all the points you made
about the underlying stuff that's going
on in gaming whether it be the gender
bias the crunch and all that stuff and
you've always talked about how proud you
are of the work that you're doing at
Kotaku
do you think your work particularly in
the past five years where a lot of these
things have has surfaced do you think
it's really moved the needle in the
industry to you you see publishers and
these companies taking notice of this
and saying we have to be more
transparent and we have to be better a
and be more transparent because this
stuff is gonna be surfaced people are
better educated about this stuff do you
see the industry being positively
responsive to this sort of stuff I hope
so
it's certainly not just us I mean plenty
of my colleagues across the board are
doing important work all the time and I
would be remiss not to mention all the
other awesome people I Kotaku so Luke
the Kirk to elective worker yeah I'll
talk about split-screen I like it was so
yeah I hope so I mean I'm kind of like a
skeptical person by nature so anytime I
hear that like your company is trying to
do better I'm looking into right now
like rockstar first Nick like we've been
doing in recent months and dan Houser is
gone now they're their co-founder and
one of the top people of the company and
I'm kind of
I've been talking to people and trying
to figure out the the the effects of
that so the answer is I hope so and yeah
I mean I we are certainly not the only
people who have been doing this this has
been talked about for a long time
there's been a lot of great work done
over the years and and like like even
just the fact that people are talking
about it more and more is is fantastic
and like if I can contribute to any
small part of that that was very very
happy that's what we glad you showered
that light on it I know you got to go so
I'm gonna get you out of here but all
first of what I want I could talk about
the book I'm working on oh that is that
has been shaping up it actually went
through its own kind of like reboot
actually I've over the course of writing
this book I've like run into all these
problems that I write about all the - I
just publish I once a couple years ago
so my editor at HarperCollins on the
first book it was great this guy Eric
Myers do like really got in and love
games past together he quit
getting shuffled around chance that that
led to a whole lot of drama but anyway
so the book is it's actually about like
volatility in the video game industry
and what happens when game studios shut
down so I'm in going and talking to a
lot of different people have been
through that sort of thing and I haven't
really talked about this publicly so you
guys cluesive let's go let's go yeah it
should be really interesting I mean and
that I think if anything is like people
talk about crunch line and that's good
but if anything is like the biggest
problem in games
it's that volatility because so many
people work in games you talk to anyone
anyone who's been in the games industry
for more than five years chances are
very high that they have moved across
the country or across the world they
were on in a layoff and they had to go
somewhere else or there's a shutdown and
they had to go somewhere else and he was
it's the same story over and over again
and so one of the things I've been doing
is trying to explore that volatility
tell stories about the volatility and
trying to see if there are solutions to
making things better or at least
alleviating those those probably part of
the whole problem is that like you're
crunching crunching crunching working on
these hour
and then your game comes off and come up
comes out and then all the money goes to
the people at the top and then you get
laid off the next day the the the rhythm
we keep seeing that's the cycle that
keeps happening so oh that's me is
really the the biggest problem in wow
that's awful
I feel like May you you need to go to
therapy after you it's crazy Batman he's
telling the truth because we've had
developers or you know shout the to turn
and a couple other people develop sound
you know people move their lives they
move their curtain your whole career for
this belief in this in this game and to
hear the results and then your hand
about you know certain CEOs getting a
big bonus and then at the same token
you're hearing you know eight hundred
four hundred people got laid off so this
is huge I'm glad you're attacking a
subject cannot wait for you to pull that
book out on volatility and just culture
I'm even the Crytek stuff you know it
was reported as far as you know people
not getting paid and you know it's just
crazy stuff so last thing is you gotta
go we do this fun thing with all our
guests and I gotta give up we do it to
you which is I need Lord Jason tries top
five video games or franchises of all
time let's go let's go you're the spot
baby you're the hospital bro god I can
give you five games off the top of my
head but like nobody can be like oh my
god you're so inconsistent like you said
these games another time because they
make Alyssa like my top 50 games of all
time okay so I can I'll just name five
randomly but like don't hold me to this
is like Jason's favorite five let's go
number one I'm gonna go really recent
number one Oh legends are the breath of
the wild the greatest game journalist
ever Lord Jesus Riya mom and the girls
oh that's it turtle that's internal boy
like knew he was mommy likes the Skyward
Sword so every time every time they now
it's anything that's not breath of the
wilder for Scarlett sword they had to
call me as you could see
that means the number one jordo is for a
reason that's that's why see you with
that great discontinued yeah
number two Final Fantasy 6 number three
super mario world's number four sweet
cut in two I'm a big fan of like stories
and games and I'm torn I'm like a few
different options of this man yeah I
could go in so many different directions
I can go like I could go Last of Us like
you got Red Dead Redemption just in
terms of like the greatness of the game
just in terms of like its outsized
impact on my life
that might have to be in there in there
just like in the way that is affecting
me but you know what I'm actually gonna
go to different actually I'm gonna go
with Starcraft 2 oh boy it's like like I
don't know it's like I I love I don't
know it's like a heroin addict
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the row absolute pleasure hope to
have you back so top of the future where
can define people find you we know you
got the new book covered what else yeah
I mean you can check my Twitter is Jason
Shire and if you find if you look there
the pin tweet has a link to the tiny
letter like it's a newsletter where I'm
gonna be updating stuff about I posted a
couple updates I'm gonna have more
updates on there about the new book
especially when people can pre-order it
because pre-ordering is super helpful
did you know that like the only way you
can get on the bestseller list basically
is if you have enough pre-order so like
justify so if you want to be a
best-seller if you want me to get
another bestseller I would appreciate it
very much thank you thank you no no
right now you can just sign up to my
mailing list where you can't i'll send
updates and then once it's available for
pre-order it doesn't even have a name
yet so if you got any name suggestions
send yeah but once it's on available
advertising non-stop yeah his old books
really good too I can't begin to
describe to you the detail that these
stories have never do it in a lifetime
it was absolute pleasure man thank you
so much for what you do in your
investigative reporter you haven't me
just it's just fantastic please enjoy
your day you always welcome back in the
run with love to pick your baby more and
you have a good day about that you got a
run in and get the little one and the
wife you so salut I lost a large Asus
Ryan never go piece so you already know
man we got to get all with the show
fantastic section by the Lord let me
address something in the chat yeah look
we don't need this extra stuff I see in
this chat why there's actually four no
people being X direction like attacking
people on personal levels yeah can we
please come down on that just
[Laughter]
if you wanna go and attack them you
attack them in color okay no cussing you
know at the end of the day I do kind of
want to chat I don't want people to be
scared to say something cuz I don't want
people to have that notion if I say
someone in that in the chats gonna
attack me right I want it to be civil in
the chat too at each other that's fine
but don't get disrespect we saw few
apologies for that guys but we needed it
but we had limited time y'all so we had
to come over case off ow - LM LMNOP Oh
with the $2 super chat why Sony comeback
I'm making more game I just think they
focused they're more focused on triple-a
stuff so it takes longer to make those
games maybe indie stuff coming up
lower brat with the $2 to pitch at Jason
preference PC or console as someone who
listens a lot suits with green I think
it's PC I think it's 66 69 with the
finalist X cloud who did that thanks
Jason for everything you do top notch
that was fantastic that we got to keep
it we got to keep it pushing read them
but you guys like we had him for an hour
we already put him way over that he was
squeezed and he definitely stuck around
as long as he possibly could you know it
was that was a really nice and to be
especially because he's a shout outs
dizzy shout out slow shout out Bradley
I tried to hook y'all up as best I could
I so that because I know yet the media
bias you know your boy did is if they
try to do is journalism or to just cuz
it's you brat we're just gonna we got to
be real everyone put fraud alerts in
that chat for Brad yo rap set it off
yeah one of the best questions he baby
good do ask the free reading question
you do what he knew I was gonna do it
you know Sony care about dreams
aka projects party look I like project
it was dream she's on a completely
different look let's get into the show
y'all we got some show a little bit of
show left so look at the poll poppin
last week poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent statements by Phil Spencer
that Xbox views Amazon and Google as
their main competitors going for it do
you think this is a mistake
by Microsoft to not include Sony and
Nintendo as direct competitors the
winner of the razor was that that razor
close if it was 73% Jesus with but the
vote was cloud infrastructure is the
long-term play for the future
Phil in the head of the curve with cloud
coming in a second and only 80 percent
damn Xbox is being dominated by Sony and
Nintendo and the console space they need
to focus on exclusive content and then
last at only 8% I don't care until
stadia and Amazon get some actual games
I care about so shout out to all those
who participated Lord solve what you
feel about this area basically don't
care about what you're talking about
because they be going into engagements
[Music]
Lovett Evo just can't wait to see the
animated was yes graphic God we know
about that shot at the brat fire I said
you could throw me in the bushes so law
relates it's the right Bush puff puff
puff pet oh you are moving along good
Sunday the Lord's Day Lord King you are
up lot of station dressed oh sorry
breaking news
breaking goals loss off Bob a big right
before the show went live we got some
news coming in that PlayStation has
announced the closure of all of its
official forums on a scale meaning oh
you know kind of all the underlying
forms have been around since like the
PlayStation 2 days where people go for
like not necessarily tips how to work
with the system and things like that
people that go back and forth a bit on
these forums for years they're shutting
that down completely as of February 27 I
understand they wanted globally make
they probably want everything under a
global PlayStation banner right sort of
beautiful that's kind of what they've
been doing but to shut down the forms so
abruptly and not necessarily tell you
what the replacement is gonna be if any
is is weird to me
he's so break it down so I've like
educate me because this this happened
literally right before we there's more
alive loot or whatever so what did he's
form this is just what are these forums
about give I don't know what's going
they've they were always in place for
people like PlayStation owners at
PlayStation fans to either it was kind
of like the mini reddit of PlayStation
ok if you had issues with your console
like that's from a technical perspective
anybody who had had knowledge of that
stuff that stuff will be in there that
we form that um specific game related
stuff where technical issues are just
talking about the game all of these
forms were were kind of there for you
right same thing is like I said what red
it does now or reset era or something
like that the thing about it is that
they've always been under the
PlayStation banner PlayStation as I
supported them they've had the server's
open for them for years since the
beginning of the internet era right so
ps2 OG xbox and they're just saying
we're starting all of this down and Oh
got you you don't want to support those
services anymore you know if you if
you're thinking forward thinking and
you're saying okay we're gonna focus on
whatever on Twitter or whatever other
social media platforms that are more
forward-facing now and cool we'll do
that
they didn't say anything they just said
we're shutting them down this thing
which is like two weeks away and they
didn't give a reason why or a potential
replacement again maybe they have some
big thing to announce they're about
unifying the Sony platform the
PlayStation platform and everything's
gonna be under one thing or whatever a
case be but at least from the onset they
have not talked about it let's deal with
the hopefully they might you know now
what you're gonna do now and what do
y'all need like what's going on what's
going on in your head what do you really
need to understand that things are
changing a change is gonna come
and Jim dance move I don't really care
how you feel there's a new sodium on
baby we don't care about the past you
just care about the future he's going
forward with his business Sony and I'm
truly believe I like his vision at Sony
oh my god Eddie what's the facts when it
comes to something like this I feel like
they shut them down and probably the
next like months they're gonna rebrand
them to something else I mean it could
be the other way around you know when
you start shooting entire forms down
it's not good there's a reason for that
but I don't think it's there
I don't think we're nowhere near like a
like the rooms on fire I just think
those some of those forms have been open
for like 15 plus years good they want to
rebrand them they want them looking
better they
want to have a more of a centered going
toward here on forward clearly they're
changing how things are going
mm-hmm yeah it is definitely definitely
dues to be I didn't I didn't know about
this until Sauber it sort of slows ask
it again
what forums is this he just was clarify
again I would think what did you lose
[Laughter]
King wants me at that name says what did
you lose PlayStation community forum so
I don't know if that includes because
you know sometimes they'll drop like an
announcement in there in like their the
PlayStation feed for I don't even know
its specifically what it's called in
violent this encompasses that right yeah
that's the case they still need a way to
get information out to to their friends
so I don't know right now what you got
is a logo baby shot out the cloche out
the lock that's old or gene he said they
use the PlayStation Blog for News poll
shouted Jonathan be with the file of
super chat the forums are coming back
eyes with a de jure logo at the bottom
we could take from this man is let's get
some into the bushes exactly what Saudi
just did what they sign up for the forum
because usually looking forward to the
forum next week guess what happened
we will get more information as it comes
in and again we're just putting this out
now we just heard he down so lord King
you up you got the bushes all in the
chase started your provocateur this is
where I did the research behind it right
because a lot of times you know that
super chat that super chests for you sir
[Laughter]
was beautiful thank you for referencing
that the way he did it he put his hands
up like this so the guy thought he was
gonna hit his gloves oh when he started
to throw his hand the left hook came out
so quick and he hit him when he it was
just it was flawless he shot the element
appeal new and exciting ways to the
bushes yes let's go what's going on with
the PlayStation 5 the prices what's
going on right listen let's check it out
right so I told y'all before that
something was looking funny with their
money we figured it out because you know
all information is flying out of China
right now because they got to make sure
that we know what's going on in China
shout-out to know what's going on in
China right now because of the epidemic
out there now shout out to the epidemic
Shantanu was going on said in the light
marrow it seems that Sony is having a
little bit of a difficulty when it comes
to paying for chips if I'm sure that's
that
[Laughter]
they said your that'll be uh 454 over
before hundred 450 per box excuse me
[Music]
like right now these chips what you
trying to do and then go fit in their
price if you don't got the 450 per box I
don't think we could work with you Sony
is potentially gonna have to scale back
or they're gonna have to pony up pony up
for a box and is in essence you are
going to have to pony up so you know are
they gonna sell it at a loss are they
gonna sell it coaster price how do you
feel with this shortage and the price
differences that's going on right now
does that hurt Sony does that put them
in a position where they're gonna have a
wait-and-see then they push them back a
year does that push them back six months
let's get some clean up good clean
nothing yes we know you do a degree bill
you do but uh yeah so let brace the what
cake is saying yes the manufacturer
costs yes have been determined to be 450
per unit due to a scarcity of parts
shout out to while the Galaxy S 20 out
here stealing everybody's what is it in
RAM and you know say then and day out
here mandolin and in RAM and take it
everybody components so you say filled
average Maximus Spencer strategically
made the deal with Samsung so that they
could have a monopoly they could spoke
aspire on these parts so that Saudi
would have today would have to pay for
it was that what we doing
when you said this date they were
talking they say you what they got new
box you know come on man take a little
couple of dollars did find out what's
going on in a box using that chipset
this would be use it then simply call
Samsung Samsung I heard y'all was using
that chip so yeah you'll wrap it up get
these out March let's get all this all
these chips and let's make it tight only
wallet whatever it's so feel
strategically did this this is a
powerful Dominus Maximus Spencer sir I
see your vision brother you say King is
order something Johnny Goudie said dad
gate all right yeah out of control movie
a look at Christopher Hart so dude
everything knows everything we are
speculating so look here's the deal so
we got that going on as far as the parts
and stuff so again manufacture look like
it's up to 450 and those internal you
know just sony bait right now they're
kind of in this wait-and-see approach
because they want to know you know what
they should do as far as either you
obviously again this is 450 without
though what is it the manufacturing no
this is just this is before they pay the
retailers right pay to sell the product
right they pay the retail so down it
brought exactly so so at that point they
wouldn't look at that like 556 possible
right but at that put a comparison to
win the ps4 launch because it looks like
manufacturing for them was about 381 so
then look some some launching at four
they made a profit every console right
so the question now becomes to what King
is saying you know is Sony because that
ain't is wait-and-see approach you know
what Mike so it's gonna do with the Xbox
series X are they willing to take a loss
with it you don't I'm saying and not get
profit to kind of keep it at 400 even
though they would be losing you know I'm
saying a profit or do they come out at
five with the risk that maybe bounce off
the series X drops at Fox let's give it
the attic what do you dig man where
we're at with this whole damn I think
that suckers sitting that
six-hundred right now oh yeah I think
that Sony wants to sell it at 600 but
they don't know what if Microsoft comes
out at 600 I think they're going to
launch theirs at 600 or maybe try to do
like $50 less which most companies don't
try to do $50 less it's harder to sell
like that hundred dollar gap but knowing
how much you know you're not taking the
consideration a lot of different factors
with that you know manufacturing it's
gonna go up a little bit and and that's
just to manufacture it that's not right
in fact so they're gonna want to add
money on top of that says they can bring
a little bread home so you know it could
be five they could drop it to five but
if it costs well you said four forty
fifty four fifty just to make it are you
talking about anything else they can
easily take the hell I think what's
gonna happen right now is they want to
see what's on Microsoft as if Microsoft
drops a $500 Series X they're gonna take
the L they're gonna take the hit they're
gonna drop 500 right now I think both
coy so you take away you think they
coming out at six I think both consoles
right now at six and they're trying to
see who drops first to see if Microsoft
dropped but they say if the manufacturer
is 450 they can still make a profit at
500 yeah I don't think they can if you
put all the the stuff it takes to to put
into this console it's probably gonna be
500 with with all the ship you gotta
consider they start to pay game stop
with them to sell this sucker they still
have to pay pay all the manufacturing
plans to make it I mean but they say
right now with the 450 unit cost and a
similar gross margin extra cause that's
right assuming that it includes all
those they're saying that the bloomberg
article say the PlayStation 5 retail
price would have to at least be 470 so
it looks like they come in at 599 to
make a profit they're scared and let's
say Microsoft says all right you know
what let's push the envelope because our
pockets are deeper right let's push the
envelope and let's put this at five or
500 right let's say they're selling at a
loss at five
right right let's gonna be a loss I know
that I I agree with ya let's say
Microsoft is selling at a loss for 500
let's say it costs like 515 the 522 by
right question
so they sell it at 499 all right Sony
even if they sell it for 99 right at any
they will be making a profit per box
Microsoft will take a loss per box right
but then you get the power disparity no
this is the difference right before they
were cheaper well you know your power
right now let's see the difference now
is there at the same price the power for
power but see I grew chicken life says
450 does not include production and
logistics and you know associated said
the parts of 450 they have to build it
ship it and pay for retail is 500 would
be a tiny profit for them I don't think
500 they're profiting from I don't know
they said they said that in a Bloomberg
article that they would make a profit
out once a ball force ever needed at
least we got snitch yeah guess ditch
okay um I was going to say that Sony
pockets got holes but then I remember
saw got no pockets can show Jonathan B I
heard to save money the PlayStation 5
doesn't come with a power cord or a
power button greatness of a king you're
making a point
again if let's say they slowly says okay
we need to be profitable let's say that
internally that cuz that was going on
right it's an internal fighting some
people saying wait and see some people
are like yo we may profit last year on
our best systems we need to make profit
again so this is the battle so everyone
say you'll come down come down wait
until Microsoft go then let before we
react right so let's just say Microsoft
does with King says right a micro so
says hey III it's 500 right yeah and
let's just say hypothetically the the
part of Sony in-house that says yeah we
need to make a profit because above the
470 right and they say 500
to Kings Point can they both be 500 with
the series X technically from all rumors
we excel as the twelve hours being the
superior can they afford that dialogue
prime deals that they prod me feel
solved they may have to come down before
eat them that's the thing I need I don't
think they're winning on Microsoft to
see how they can undercut them which I
think waiting on Microsoft for
permission to do yes same thing as them
that's like if Microsoft the guys who
are in second place are willing to sell
their Council of five they're thinking
is okay we can sell ours at five and
armed and make a profit yeah our brand
recognition is gonna carry us over this
this is what I say to that this is the
caveat right this is where the problem
comes in for Sony now Microsoft has the
secret weapon done talked about the s
and I think Microsoft's willing to take
a loss on both now let's say the S comes
in at 350 400 0:08 pigeonholes the Sony
in you can't say we're going to be the
same price with less power you can't say
we're gonna be the same price with you
just have to worry about our games it's
gonna carry us through who when a box
can tell you you get in the boxes I
already know they're gonna put game pass
still in my place they tell you all you
need to go home and play 200 games is
the purchase opposed to when you go
purchase a PlayStation birthday when
they start doing like let's say they do
a chart comparison
do you know for the layman do and it go
all right when you get an Xbox Siri X
you get 200 games because in every box
there's game pass and when you go
purchase a PlayStation 5 you must
purchase a game you must purchase a
controller you must purchase this you
must purchase that and then the out
number comes over $600 who that person
looking at the chart is gonna say oh
financially I'm against
to go this way right right I would just
say this is this is fun shout-out to
shroom faces gotta gotta get it I feel
like if Sony was wanting to launch the
console at 500 I don't think they would
be scared of caught of Microsoft
launching their platform at 500 I don't
know they they've been killing the
entire industry the solar generation
they clearly had the world on their side
they have the better exclusives going
into this I'm sure they don't game fest
but they do got whatever their there's a
global brand they do bring the only
reason that they would wait is that
their console was it 500 it was more and
that's what they're going off of but
this is good because it's like I hate
you
out of you you're saying you're saying
that peace yes yes because they came out
and they did something
Sony never saw coming they say our
stuffs right here at the vga sony never
saw that coming my Phil Spencer said
they were they were saying a game pass
ad if it was like in day and he said
there's only like four people in the
room they were hiding that from Sony to
not just not just the the consumers they
don't want no one knowing that series X
was coming out on the video game award
because when you put out the video with
the series X you show it's that big you
know what's gonna be powerful Sony
doesn't want to come out they don't want
to have they don't want to be the same
price going into what the series acts
because they know it's gonna be weaker
they want to be cheaper but at the same
time if they were 500 and we all pretty
much assume the series X is gonna be 5
to 600 if they if they both were gonna
be at 500 I don't think Sony would care
because I like look we might be the same
price right but we have the better games
going into it regardless what people
think we have this entire generation on
our back to me right a lot so pull the
back over at 600 that's what let me let
me ask you this anecdote what about like
you said they know that a global brand
they know they got the exclusive right
what if they just say yo we why can't
why don't they just say we 500 right now
why the wait now on 500 that's why such
Microsoft's gonna be at 6 they have no
problem being at 6
but what if ok alright ok I understand
what you're saying like why shoot
yourself in the foot
and put a low price when Microsoft can
go high make mad money we got the super
chat one second shrinking the files over
there
PlayStation file will ship with the
controller but you have to swipe your
credit card on the built-in card reader
will get you here in a second at the
other day I just feel personally feel
like if they Beaufort at 500 Sony would
have announced it by now I see you I see
your business acronym and this is I'm
saluting right now because you what you
just did was you just did business 101
right why the hell should we give you
our price if we don't know these guys
price if they say sick why would we like
ourselves to 500 right if they say 600
we can say 550 we can say 575 would you
make the larger private they're going
into this generation is the w they're
going in trying the entire population
what if they're if they're six and they
don't know if they should go five cause
it's if they go six and they announce it
what they want to be 6 and then
microsoft announces that this shit's 5
that mean that's $100 difference they
don't want that they want to be neither
on the same level as Microsoft or they
don't want Microsoft being lower that's
what you're saying is what you're saying
is you you feel that Sony is comfortable
financially being financially on par
price-wise going into the next
generation you just don't want to be a
part where they're $100 more in the
weaker like Microsoft that's what I said
it feels like they're kind of it once
Microsoft sets their price right that's
that's a green light for them to set it
at the exact same price and they and
they're gonna let you know the
PlayStation faith will carry them over
mm-hmm what it for whatever the power
deficiencies they may be or not be right
I think that that's the smart that's the
move you make when you're
leading the pack back of the pack but
let me ask this that let's play devil's
advocate we're getting on them with you
know the pricing and stuff like that but
what about these same manufacturing
issues right that we're hearing what
about its effect on the only series X
could series X have these manufacturing
costs that you know I know sir I know
King has is his third eyes open and safe
circuit if Phil is like this controller
your bag with that so kid is in the bell
to kiss boom for this topic
you know what's up good mic levels good
nice good yeah we go we go so like what
about this I know we we're hearing the
Sony side from the Bloomberg report
you know what about candy same shortages
you know I'm saying effect Microsoft or
that they may have to their price may go
up as far as a manufacturing cost and I
think let's just say there's this 520
hey I think Microsoft uses manufacturers
and like Mexico and stuff to China no
yeah I note you me and as far as the the
plants and they don't have all that
manufacturing and China to rely on and
they have to rely on you know their
second party manufactures the people
they go to those don't work yeah it
could be explored we could be one of
those things where you have to reserve
your stuff degree remember oh I got a
read gaming yeah yeah game shut up the
gaming 44 the flat-out super-shot oh
dude our playstation 5 $4.99 of Xbox the
series X is $5.99 PlayStation 5 is 399
if X is $4.99 if the Xbox would wait out
songs and if he was x1 links and shadow
gene as Xbox one is x1 X is made in
China but we do know they have plants
and I believe in Mexico yeah I believe
they have Malaysia and Malaysia yeah and
then also even sewing themselves as far
as the plans they're saying right now
the coronavirus thing is not the issue
the issue seems to be this NAND and this
what you call it memory facts
smartphones because of the galaxy this s
20 out here taking it all up a shout out
to me approaches day one day one day
when they were doing that ultra getting
that old yes it's a real thing it's a
real thing for the switch out of worlds
was a shout out to my boy Jean and in
the chair he put out an article on that
animal crossing console was effective
for the switch but let's get kidding me
you know I think something needed to
have miss which is the balance of the
world Britt was the switch was winning
too hard so they had to come up with the
carnivorous came using the Coronas virus
for Picasso Wars oh no my virus is the
core never be eating crazy console
killer moving a lot kissable was up what
what do you feel with this whole you
know Saudi manufactured have to be for
thrown what do you think things land but
I couldn't wait to this information not
because the biggest I've been hyping in
an attic [ __ ] no there's something like
Yelp from from the jump like before they
even I said next-generation consoles
were gonna be 500 vanilla great I was
like in order for it to be the leap that
I want like when we're expecting at
minimum $500 and you can think Microsoft
and Sony for getting us accustom to
paying $500 on schools right right so
now it's like the new standard regional
market can sustain $500 consoles like I
you agree I mean Microsoft if Microsoft
fellow partner is too much the Xbox one
that's wouldn't facts well yeah and
listen I don't believe in that
philosophy for two things
what meaning Cognito has been going back
and forth on these stupid cell phones
all right and what he said to me was I
mean it was a logical thought process
when he when I gave him the upper end
price a he
automatically so like like like a punch
in the face
[Music]
that's the lower end yeah and then you
start to break down what you get for
your buck I truly believe that we can
sustain $600 because I don't think the
lifecycle is out of these older
generations you know I believe that the
PlayStation 4 have life the pro do you
really think and your pro has done
everything that it can for you know I
don't think my ex has done everything it
can for me it takes these new systems to
allow us to play cross-gen titles will
push our old systems to their maximum so
I believe them the the new systems is
technically a luxury
we'll be honest with you that's for us
bougie dudes who need to be at the
forefront where you don't need to go out
and get the new galaxy as 20 right you
can go buy the 10 if you haven't
purchased at me incognito sat out a
whole generation of gold because we
didn't feel that the leak was good right
this transcends directly into our
consoles if you don't feel that the
value is there you can sit pat and this
is why Microsoft is doing what they're
doing
oh by saying there's no exclusives per
se and that is going to force your hand
if you're financially not ready to make
that jump and when we're able to show
you why you need it then we can
competitively price this system at a
point that it will help you financially
you will give you a year to get your
pockets right you know so finally me and
me got our pockets right for you that
we're able to jump into this phone but
you think in your head
if $1,400 for phone is saying no it's
not saying let me get this which I get
it back to tailor shop the face 23 PK
and wild attend our super chat both
PlayStation 5 in Series X will do 4k 60
so where will the power difference will
be if any power advantage won't be no
impact Sony is the bigger and more
popular brand in more regions with
better cake shout to face BK Wednesday
so let's get back
but I do think that people are sleeping
too much on game pass next generation
and I think that's not necessarily gonna
make stuff equal ground but it's gonna
give a little bit more of an advantage
that Microsoft has yeah next-gen that
they didn't have to be listen game was a
fickle fickle as hell when you look at
what you're doing for me now if you look
at the launch of that Xbox one by the
time the console came out the only thing
that it had there there was not in his
favor only negative thing they hadn't
changed was the forcing of the Kinect on
everybody and the price point they have
none of that fun
remove the Kinect part the biggest thing
is always gonna be the press that
hundred dollar difference is it them
period that it that is the sticking
point to the vast majority of people who
went back and forth and flip-flop really
the price point the price point is I
think Trump's all of the reasons for us
all another and a hundred and I don't
think either of them at this point
well Microsoft can't do it right home
what to say Michael Shannon right I
don't think those willing to do that
hundred dollar difference right but but
here's the giveaway I'm not supposed to
give it to you case we could stop solve
you gotta be thinking though
we'd gain pass right let's just say
Michael sauce is yo we gotta make a
profit right let's let's say manufacture
for them is 520 right and they say okay
we bump this joint to six right people
at all six but part of them could say
look we got lock are at four to undercut
them right and then for the people who
want to premium they can say look you
say in six but are six hundred had let's
say takes a game past three months on
one month for game pass in every series
X you now talking about a hundred semi
games and halo infinite at launch in
your series X that's something that
PlayStation is not willing to do right
so to me yeah that's another trump card
that Microsoft could hold on it what if
what if PlayStation drops at that same
price right six or five what whatever
whatever the exact same price is right
okay and but they drop a horizon zero
dawn
I will think the dropper is not coming I
used to think that I used to think that
song but I feel like this pricing won't
be an issue they had horizon to sitting
on for a launch side I think they would
already throw that out there to the book
I don't think any of their top I think
one of the biggest issues is they're
going into a generation with no key ip's
to launch the point we don't so so it's
so if they can't really fight on that
area cuz Microsoft don't really have any
either basalt halo and halo has always
been an up and down hill these days
that's a strong bring up a demo we can't
act like gears form five scored out the
charts and like it's their good game but
they're not compared to what I'm gonna
tell you this right that that whole
narrative about it not being exclusive
to the console if they drop they don't
even have to drop horizon right if they
drop Ratchet and Clank well it may
survive it's right but if they do
yes fine the narrative is gonna find
some way to come back and be like whoa
but that Xbox Xbox one right now who's
gonna find some way to diminish I'm
gonna come at you with the Ratchet and
Clank thing call them we're already
already said he knows for a fact it's a
ps4 time okay you know you you you you
they have they're making ghost yeah I
know listen
I'm so optimistic when it comes to the
PlayStation 514 things know right
because here we're just gonna go I do
want resistance you want them to fight
back
[Laughter]
no no I'm talking about resistance to
game I wanted to be a fight I want you
to I honestly believe they have a vast
diverse portfolio they can surprise us
with something that's being made now is
it something like in the vein of I think
horizon has grown into the upper echelon
of their IPs and I don't think they
would waste it on a small portion of the
of the crowd right very earlier it'd be
too easy to bus early post in that
Avenue I would think it would be like an
older Iowa VIP like a resistance or
infamous an infamous has always launched
with them or always been in that launch
window right maybe that game can
actually show the power of the does that
better oh my god you see those recent
comments right there are active users
yeah a new metric that we they're slowly
but surely I'm acclimating the
playstation faithful to hearing those
words hmm I'm telling you just what King
said mm-hmm hmm when we talked about
early about strategies and Jason wasn't
100% sure that they would ever do they
indeed mm-hmm their conditioning you to
start hearing those words I'm telling
you right now this I don't know I don't
know the date stuff whatever happened
all the way anytime soon but listening
you to get more and more used to hearing
that type of let's get kidding me okay
wait what you feel all this myth all
right a couple things I want to point
out all right the first thing that whole
price thing if you guys I don't know if
you guys remember but like the Xbox one
the original like the VCR stopped being
500 dollars in June of 2014 that's when
they removed the Kinect box yes for me
so
it's only been like a $5 for like the
six months and believe it or not the
first six months of the the console was
actually selling pretty well right so
but they got rid of that narrative
pretty early in a generation
hey the Xbox was at $500 again until the
Xbox 1x right came out so the reason my
whole thing about the pricing is right
Sony every since the whole development
of like the PS 5 Sony I think it's funny
of both Microsoft both knew that these
consoles we're gonna be like $5 plus it
especially Sony they seemed with the air
even though they seem quiet now they
were the first more open talking about
the places to buy right they've been
talking about it says like yeah a probe
2019 minute outer but I don't dig kid
you don't think that a lot of it is a
surprise cuz the vibe is if they're in
this wait and see and I don't know say
they're panicking but it almost feels
like this costing drew them off like
they thought they know Bob was like 800
days will be for honey it was gonna be
cheap and that's why BG lost this money
to me they're not so you're not
surprised at that
oh man it's costing us so much money
you're surprised because Xbox already
showed the Xbox Series X and they look
like it's gonna be a beast and and and
they're like they're like wait if
they're gonna sell that for $500 and we
might have a little problem and it's cuz
they know they know for sure that they
wanted to retell their PS 5 and ain't no
right now this is the time that ended up
right they won't announce the price in
February right but they know what they
want to sell it for they want to sell
this console for $500 now their problem
is the Xbox Series X is out there has
been shown they they know what they're
working they know what AMD did for the
series X they know what they're working
with is like you know what it's probably
gonna be it's probably gonna be more
powerful yeah we want to be the cheaper
console but then they just don't know
what filling them is gonna do right this
is like they got needing to probably
know all right if they drop lock hurt
I'm not too worried about that but if
you tell
if their price cap is $5 and they're
still expected to be more uh well that's
a problem we have a problem with it and
Sony's best interests we built is nice
like he typically does and price that
series XS $600 if he prices that Xbox
Series XS 6 $3 the play C 5 can
comfortably be fi okay all right kid saw
King do like this ever since that award
show your eyes have been open y'all and
realized this is not the same old fill
this is the feel like King been talking
about for a minute all of a sudden now
people are saying that you know don't
think he's gonna go back to that what
you just said you Joe you know play nice
Phil Philly been playing nice since that
day anything that they've done phil has
thwarted them in every avenue they say
okay your thoughts I was gonna get a
little show this month in February to
figure out what was going on with their
PlayStation fire what Phil said February
we're gonna be a good mom
what y'all said what the hell feels like
you you don't understand like oh boy is
out here with his petty out pause and of
course y'all think yeah you know oh we
got to do is wait for Microsoft Atlantic
y'all been doing the same old tactic for
years yeah that's like Microsoft go
first and we come behind Phil can wait
you out now so so Philly going down
surprising III we go sell you can do you
know you can do Sony ain't gonna be at
e3 he can show you games game box all
that statistics he's on the tape no Hoda
hold up we let you talk okay did we get
kidnapped
the end of the day uh it's whoever
cracks first yeah oh
if so nice all right Phil is really
putting it to us but now we got a way to
July them a week lanai now it's our
stuff in August but production goes in
August right kick jumping what's going
on come on big is happening kill me
here's the thing they need that well one
they don't want to wait until July or
August and I'll surprise they need those
pre-orders up by e3 around budget for it
you need the pre-orders they get get
that buzzing and so does playstation if
Sony that's the that's the tricky thing
it's like I don't care what happens
where it what they announced the Xbox
series X at the PlayStation 5 will not
be $400
they're not taking L they're not gonna
cuz you know how long it will take for
them to profit yeah but all right all
right in defense though Playstations one
through three they all took they didn't
promote they took a loss of knows
PlayStation 4 is always systems that
they made a profit on that's the only
one they get late and to do that had to
remove the camera at a dealer in those
first couple generations I think
PlayStation was in a different play
place financially to be able to take
that loss I don't think they're there
anymore
I figured you say it shut up we gotta so
J we got the cost of everything and how
was how was it in each generation right
oh she's remembering know by the time
remember a PlayStation with one came out
what 95 yeah about there or 95 in you
know the ps2 come on 2000 and stuff like
that and a tortilla they sold at a loss
at first button they were doing it on
like meat competition you gotta
understand they had an opportunity you
see what they did with the ps4 at a
profit
yeah why go back if you don't have to
take the first beginning couple
generations - that was beginning of
gaming - that can't really ask too much
out of these price it sit until your
point in into a kid's point you know
banks off of these guys have established
that you know gamers will pay five
hundred dollars for an Xbox one X or
whatever and it seems to be culpable we
know 608 that Detroit but let me get
these to be checked or face 23 K&Y 10
hours of chat I highly doubt a lot of
people are gonna give up everything they
purchased on ps4 this
and was the worst gentle ooze for Xbox
it's gonna be hard to convince people to
switch over I agree with you but this is
where Phil comes in this Maki this is
how it happens he go one can screw the
Phil smacking Walker no you take the
glove off and go Jim dance moves Ryan's
gonna have game pass on PlayStation
father oh my god here we go
shot gaming Forte with the file a
sandwich at five for $4.99 is a great
price but why not spend $100 more I
understand the trepidation but some
people blow that on a one-night stand
treat your hobby but I feel you I mean
40 I feel you I know the hardcore we
don't care we're there day one the
question is you know historically 600 is
always seemed as you know I'm surprised
at you I'm surprised at you for this you
are on the front lines you see people
come in and I want you to think about it
how many times has somebody sat there
and saw a price for one thing and then
looked over and saw something else that
was cheaper and went with something else
that was cheaper yeah all right it's
it's it's finances here we're dealing
with you know $100 for some people is a
hell of a lot of bread so I don't care
and I feel the guy that went inside to
buy an xbox and bought him and brought a
Playstation walking out the store
because it was a hundred dollars cheaper
a hundred dollars is a hell of a lot for
some people for me that's some lessons
something else's I don't know what it is
but a hundred dollars could be a pair of
sneakers for my kid anything can den
hundred dollars could be anything well
why waste a hundred dollars when I can
game someplace else right it's just a
bit I let our kids all finish up I mean
got one more pitch at $3 super chat love
this podcast King smooth drop in facts
this is this manufacturing thing is
definitely heating up the cars y'all got
a lot of faith it Uncle Phil
[Music]
- outta my way g-man from the love lunch
gave me that net launch games will be
$120 so Microsoft has wiggle room with
game passes and that's comin coming -
Marty I think unless I wanted to be 500
I would love both to be 500 like and
then let the battles begin let the gays
machine again and see what happens you
know I'm saying I'm curious if Microsoft
does announce 500 if Sony eats it goes
for and then I thought happened
I want know well I can't go drink who
gets fired sony says full whoa you can
guarantee nothing comes in your box you
know you're gonna look at the back of
the box you say though they comes with
the call so you get to buy the wires the
HD box you don't roll they go digging
down there go digging down the oh listen
we got a Jaguar was doing the same thing
in Sony no somebody's fired automatic no
that's not a goat is that a blessing bet
it can't have bad yourself out here fine
like you said if Microsoft is five with
the more power
do you know what that narrative would be
you thought resolution was bad
remember them digital foundry articles
come out and rich and Ledbetter with the
smooth English voice and John letting me
come out there be like we're gonna know
the ray-tracing in this the frames per
second you know it would be crazy out
here and he did you got to go for if
Michael if Phil comes out with his petty
and says you know what fine what's good
out here right day in a tough spot day
in a tough spot but if they go for at
least they could say yo we
cheaper this is a pricey I used to wear
this little red remember what I say $400
I want everybody to pick up in you know
in your box milk carton crazy take into
that is whether or not Microsoft would
take at the end of the day Microsoft has
been very vocal that they care about the
console space but they don't care about
yeah that's my boy see what they look
like we have no problem taking you know
even a 50 to 100 dollar loss well we're
just gonna bundle game pass and
everything that's what I'm mark with
that Microsoft or Sony game person if
they like the game press games they
gotta go bot diggin Micah so he said you
do not to actually take that L right but
I think the console and how it shakes
and how it visually looks is super
aggressive they didn't take the casual
approach to this make it look like
anything else they're like we're going
to reshape how these are made
right and naica say yo this is the
premium box right we still got lock hard
out here they still say yo we got
lockhart chilling and then the other
thing is we know like we said we gonna
go back to the main point our Lord and
Savior Yoshida said just like Phil
Dominus active users a subscription
there's the new meta venture that's the
new wave now all that consoles the
biggest problem is its February 16th
we're talking about PlayStation 5 min
your factoring cost and potential cost
and we still haven't seen the console
yet
I'm so console looks like the dev kit if
you throw an appearance of a console
people are gonna be at you even more for
the price they don't want to do anything
it took my constructor mm-hmm going back
to the manufacturing issues were talking
about before right and he said
potentially another issue is that
because it was developed it's designed
that way it had heat dissipation is yeah
so they're spending a lot on the cooling
I heard a cooling is up to you just get
rid of that little shoe horn shaped
thing and just make a pyramid you know
where to king every quarter of the
pyramid gonna be a district listen last
comment I got to speak to Sony to the
CEO on the Lord and Savior you Sheeta he
said that business should be judged by
the number of active users not the
number of hardware units sold some Sony
game staff think it should sell the new
console at a loss if necessary just to
match my croissants price while others
so the executives say they would prefer
to make money as the company date with
the ps4 this is an internal struggle
yaar we will see how this thing plays
out it's going down to the wire this is
fun I love it can't wait Jim Ryun what
got a promotion right good I want you to
ps4 this is an important decision on yes
yes yes job is to make s ie money you go
far you guys you said that actually
listen the active user comment is coming
from the people who have a stable job
he wore unstable said we need to make
money now I just don't feel comfortable
what's going on here let's make our
money upfront you know and somebody
who's not the people that's comfortable
in their pockets are able to say you can
pay me back whenever you get it you've
got other people that are not
comfortable in a pocket so you're
listening I need my money on Tuesday
give my money back Tuesday
so the money back on Tuesday Tuesday
guys you definitely hit it the rhetoric
change when you said it and if you close
your eyes and you listen to it you heard
that before we're going to go by the
metric of active users where the hell
have you heard that before
oh that's from Microsoft listen listen
what I'm saying is if it's not in color
[Laughter]
if you got those emojis that you pay for
let's do that I'll join you with this
watching your pockets laughing because
we got a real thing is are we gonna do
this filth but if we're not gonna skip
this bill Sprint's or comments you might
just tie it into tighter and tighter get
tied it okay so I've tied it tie that in
and then I'll do I'll do it Keighley
after this
so first principles work on the
thousandth episode of gamertag rates a
little Paris fantastic a lot of podcast
yes what thousand well and he made
continued that's what we need a camera
on you
[Laughter]
they asked a lot of questions about you
know him taking over and the things that
had to be done when he took over
obviously a cancel game scalebound he
talked about stuff like that but I think
the most interesting stuff that came out
of that interview was that phil was
talking about they asked him about his
aggressiveness now right and and their
stance and it's funny we were talking
just talking about that about how
they've come out aggressively they
showed the console early in a play say
we didn't expect and in this interview
Phil specifically use the words we're
not going to be meek like me in a way
I've never seen anybody like like Tibet
was the perception before and we've
talked about when you have the
opportunity to put the boot on the neck
do it even if you're your opponent isn't
necessarily there or they're not there
for the toe-to-toe head-to-head battle
just keep putting the boot on the neck
right it's something that we talked
about PlayStation doing all the time you
know Xbox is minding their business and
they still walk right by them no they
were still there you need a bully kick
your ball over the yard look whenever we
have the opportunity to do so we're
going to be bullish and bully-ish about
the things that are that we're gonna
announce that we know people gonna be
excited about and that's me was kind of
more candid than I expected him to be
about that sort of stuff right and I
think are they Oh true it's gonna be
some real interesting stuff and he
looked back to the pricing stuff like he
did say they don't want to be beat or
power in price they're gonna be let's
get there Victor out the victor analyst
a great show guys you guys are killing
it salute Vic thank you much love salute
yeah all I'll say about I listen to it
you know fantastic interview what I got
I would I got from me you know he
definitely seems very confident there's
no question at all sets any meekness
this is this is him all day this is the
photometer Spencer KB talk yet he was a
dude I told you that was Dedic I was
like now feel like the shake hands and
kiss babies
boy listen I know it when I looked in
his eye no juggler he showed me like he
had the look in his eye like if you give
me the opportunity know what famously I
bet this has been my gun now looking it
takes a couple years to get these asses
in the right place
oh yeah basically and I know it analysis
or progression never saw it and when you
when you pick somebody like it's a horse
did it when you go to the horse track
and you pick a horse and you just don't
know you just like you're that horse
look like he got that stuff good right
and a horse take off from the gate and
he blow out the did the yard like and he
wins you feel good about yourself when
everybody was in there like now your
horse is trashed my doing this horse is
gonna kill y'all on guard in there oh
god listen I will say like I said
interview he's very confident
I liked his I don't say about the people
who did the interview they didn't hold a
lot of punches back shot the powers in
the meadows of the people they they was
in their bag and like I said I like what
he said about Japan
I love the reading folk I love that he
said and this is this goes to ungrateful
addicts cuz he came for added wonder he
said he said it burnt my soul that dumb
Japanese games were not on whatever
little place things that were on Xbox
right
that to me was huge and that that's like
basically trying to reassure like yo
that's not
on next-gen we've were establishing that
and then I love what he said about the
studio thing having a presence over
there that to me is huge and I like what
he said about VR actually clarified his
Stevens he said you know he just wanted
to be honest that at the start of the
gen with the series X that's not
something that's gonna be there but as
he left the door open right as it
progresses and if it catches on yeah
there'd be willing to jump on and I
thought that was cool it was can
ungrateful Heydrich talk
yes Johnny be sown yet he knows about
your gratefulness contain showed me that
you know that that is something he's
clearly working on even said he's I
don't know if whatever be to a point
where everything that's in Japan will be
over here but he just show that it's one
of the biggest priorities is for it to
get as many to come over as possible
right right no definitely definitely so
that's what I got I saw that is a huge
weakness to be honest with you because
when I can get the Sun on my playstation
and you know I can't get it on my xbox I
think that's a big hole those gaps to
fix that hole to understand that's the
mark of a true leader a true leader can
see his weakness and try to fix him yeah
right and he's being transparent with ya
it's not like you see you have
weaknesses and you try to just show up
your strengths each on a front
weaknesses the whole Microsoft would
just put the bucket with the water pull
out the water they don't necessarily
gonna fix the hole that's no not at all
now that this Microsoft like alright
let's get this out of the water we gotta
fix it we've man to stay there the whole
way too long not to say that the old
Microsoft didn't try because we got we
got the blue dragon we got it on the
miss Walker games we we were in that bag
right we were it was consistent right
and I believe that we will get a level
of consistency with this type of a rain
listen listen guys filling the media
always Brett right so while he's there
appreciate him hmm because we had other
guys that were in charge that that were
equally as great any time and a 10 years
all right
and they brought the 360 to our
forefront they pushed we couldn't see it
understand so Phil is not going to
always be there you appreciate him for
what he's doing but look at the role map
that he's giving you the road map that
he's giving you is a road map of hope
going forward if this xbox generation
could have literally be done on facts
all right you notice I think that we're
gonna have issues of backwards
compatibility next-gen is if you listen
if you listen to that interview
who said I'm playing games on my
backwards-compatible that's that's on
the pre-approved list that day so I'm
thinking it's gonna be like this Shin
we're certain devout publishers and them
won't let the Game Commission in then
like I said I think we're gonna have
that issue but I mean I then also
remember like Bill still says it's not
it's not about that they can't do it
some of it is licensing issues oh yeah
they could do them all you could do them
all you know say it just comes down to
what they could get approval but took
King's point before he MoveOn his King
his job as a fire he throw some darts
ever bids us there cuz you don't have a
Peter board guy but I will say this I
will say this you know Peter board
that's that's my heart dad to me is what
brought xbox360 one of the greatest you
know consoles to the forefront their
aggressive but I have to admit what
Phil's doing the way he's handling jump
yeah he it's a better your man is a
better long time strategist and just
throwing my man was throwing money at it
shake come over right yeah like he like
yo come on we got y'all right but but
Phil is going fellas go into the hood
like pull it up and it's like yo what we
gotta do to break bread we need y'all
over here you know I'm saying we can't
be missing them games over here and then
also I love the Japanese studio talk
whether it be buying one or you don't
develop it well for scribe & nass a
difference yeah like you know another
thing I really liked he said that one of
the biggest issues that they have with
you know the Japanese market and all the
developers and publishers is they don't
like that they don't see the Xbox in
their stores and he said they
next generation will be very very strong
about that we're gonna make sure that it
comes out in Japan addressing its enemy
the last key
he gotta do if he do this is big like
what they do a career right now that s
contact people are sleeping they're
using X cloud more than the United
States right now that should be more so
it makes you know at least turn it on
turn it it oh it just it's just like
okay they we go they platinum okay cool
they still we still doing it right but
hold it the whole thing is this though
like if they get if they do what they're
doing with the SK Telecom like and they
do what they doing right with how
t-mobile you CT moment I made that move
with Sprint you see that coverage don't
get wider right you see X cloud gonna be
implemented in that joint if they do
something similar in Japan where you
link up with the biggest ISP because
let's be real as much as we could say
studio and all that imma keep it a buck
they not buying Xbox consoles we've seen
the memes and when it like y'all here's
the new Xbox is sold it'd be ten people
in the store maybe get a crown or Katoch
will be clown it'd be funny but it's
true like nobody's letting out all the
Xbox logos in the streets and come no
one's buying a console fan so let's cool
what's my buoyed up saying this was the
worst generation lose yes and Xbox is
very aware of that and that's when X X
cloud and game is gonna make up that
difference by a large margin to play X
cloud ain't for us before Asia yes go
into their t-mobile you know how we got
like a year of game passing x cloud with
their phone purchases and stuff like
that and this they're gonna jump in user
base for Xbox games is gonna jump
dramatically because of stuff like that
because of the the soft like buy-in
right everybody's buying phones and
whatnot ya see that Samsung deal is so
big a huge it's crazy
Wow like a year from now I can upgrade
my food any gonna offer me projects I
did we laugh at like you said it's not
for us we laugh I shout out to my boy GD
said cuz shout GG from London he goes to
Japan
he knows mom my boy from London gaming
down there one of the best writers out
there she's Luther he said mobile game
of the pan is unbelievable was there 40
GS the entire country plays pokemons
this is real right so again we gotta get
ourselves out of our console thinkin
that it's not gonna work again the kids
the implementation right we know over
there is a lot of 399 so they gotta if
they implement it with the ISP like it
is saying write and say yo you sign up
for you renewing your contract you
getting this one year X cloud or
whatever it is they they do to get them
in the ecosystem that's a big deal and
that's them penetrating the money but
last point that that would be I will get
if Feliz they wouldn't do that I gotta
give him the gold over my man over my
man on what you call it because it he
bomb no one was ever on the Xbox not
able to solve the the digit to Japan
riddle and that will put Phil over Peter
if he could if he can pull this off
that's something that no Xbox leadership
has been able to do and it's exciting
but um when you know how the the apps
that come inside your phone you know
when your phone you boot your phone up
yeah is a xbox game pass on the new
Samsung phones being that the deal is
done
or whatever oh is that like already like
in like a baked an app I don't know
there no way they acted it's like some
cross promotion at a go and I said more
details will be revealed later they got
some type of joint thing going with them
and I think that's that'll be huge if
you can get we're forgetting to be one
of the the baked in apps like the the
first apps that are already installed on
the phone that you don't have to go and
install that it's there and then I think
that's huge because that allows a
demographic to just say what was this
and hit the button and iOS down right
you see the baby now is that's huge
that's a huge market again yoda chatters
hey y'all captain fulfill this is nuts
it's not happy they mad they don't like
this ex cloud yo Chris who you kappa for
they said we spoke every phone really I
mean I would really love to hear you
like I said Christopher dogs funny but
it's a funny we'll see what happens
before last topic we get up out of here
this is our man good friend Geoff
Keighley met back in the news again
so I'm yeah he just made that
announcement that the um III Coliseum
will not return to III after handle it
the past couple of events okay we get it
but he said but the key statement he
said is given what has been publicly
communicated about the plans for eg 23
2020 he doesn't feel comfortable
participating in the show at this time
and then right as that happened I mean
right when he made this is right before
another leak Sony will dominate
point-blank period
Christopher Hart does not like we get
excited about the Asian market they
don't like we talked about edge cloud
and down the markets they don't like
about none of this hopeful ticket they
said the boots or the deck that they go
down it is the truth
pause pause Baris anyway
move it alone sir yeah man he basically
said that allows you to write as ESA
leaked again the plans for III so yeah
they pulled out minute naka he's not
gonna be there and I just want to bring
this to the brown you know what do we
think man you know um is this bigger
than you know it's bigger than rap yes a
you know say messing it up to the point
where dudes not feeling comfortable is
there a salad boycott going on like
what's going on you know we talked about
this in the background oh we talked
about that we feel that um well I'm my
opinion all right I'm not gonna jump
nobody else in this my opinion is I feel
that people are getting together and
they're trying to make a silent protest
they're trying to protest what's going
on and they feel that if we all pull out
at the same time we're going to show
that that the pen is mightier than the
sword
listen dude I never went to the Coliseum
oh that's not taking anything away from
the Colosseum if you're not there I
wouldn't even know if you were right but
for some people that means a lot right
and your coverage not being there means
a lot for certain people right so what
we gonna do is I assure you ESA if you
allow me to get media I will talk every
last piece of coverage that they did not
cover and I will show your Colosseum in
great detail I will show the world that
III is still viable and alive and I will
not allow these old dinosaurs to kill it
I'm a young wolf wait Michelle allow me
to be your voice box allow the world to
see that it's still the king okay I got
a comb for you now we're gonna save
people
we to save people that'd be odd so D
with information gets stolen these dudes
have now stolen information twice again
and your information would be at risk if
you mess it but you could be a stallion
but you ain't cool put your credit cards
so cold King let me tell you this right
you're saying your security is lacking
but for each and every last one of you
guys watching right now for each and
every last one I will put my security at
risk for you I've done with you out of
control if so he doesn't dominate next
year the IOP is gonna give you Derrick
Rose bees oh you know each other you
know we go you don't we kill it that's a
fact that's a fact though all like you
know we have all these companies always
leaking your stuff on accident we have
you know the Sony thing that happened in
2011 we have the I think one of the
credit be R is just leaked movies it's
like how many of these people that these
media outlets play on PlayStation to buy
some on PlayStation it's like nothing is
a hundred percent of they it was ESA
fall for what they did and they should
have took more ownership of what they
did they did they did another leak man
again definitely do a security oh the
plant and all the companies that's
Columbia they lie right right bra not a
good thing about the leak is that we
found out that shout-out to Ainsley Bowl
season game and I just found this out
that Microsoft not only is in their own
separate theater they are on the floor
as well cuz before they remember used to
be Nintendo and they're showing a big
join now I think it's the West Hall
whatever that whole his kid right I
forgot which one it is right now we also
you know so he's not gonna be there so
there's a potential you know series X's
and gonna be on the floor the backers
are trying to take advantage of of their
new console wash which would be pretty
huge you know what happened on
aggressive now what what happened was
the moment Sony - they weren't going
okay okay call the ESA look we gotta be
on that floor they ain't gonna be
because again a lot of times let's be
real we go to e3 a lot right a lot of
times if you add new to e3 if you're not
in the know you don't know about e3
Coliseum and sometimes you don't even
know that Microsoft is not in the
building and there's somewhere I bet you
80% of people in this chat didn't even
know what the Coliseum was right so
that's it so that's it's a it's a big
deal so it's it's cool to see Marcus
I'll take advantage it I mean listen but
the key thing I'm gonna be real I am
saddened by that you know I know we've
had our issues with Kili or certain
things but I can't get mad at him for
this like you know when you when you
when you look at reason that he gave
right he says he says this is very
important a lot of people but III needs
to be a more global and be more digital
right specifically he didn't say
anything about any of the activations or
the celebrities I didn't say anything
about that so when and when you look at
how successful he was with the game wars
in particular this year how it's grown
every single year specifically how it
reached more people right I think he's
at the point where he's kind of his own
entity now when it comes to this sort of
stuff he doesn't need them right good
yeah correct me if I'm wrong he was sort
of the impetus for all for the judges
weak stuff running up t3 right so he's
saying all of that stuff is still
happening he's he's running that stuff
but it's not part of a three at all it's
gonna happen so again it's like it feels
like his stock as as an entity himself
and being able to handle this stuff in
himself he's risen to the point he
doesn't need true beat rule 3 I agree
with all I said but you again I saw I
want it I don't want to understate like
the fact that it seemed based on his
statement of saying uh at this point I'm
not comfortable it's like you've seen
something you don't like oh yeah that
they do and then the day of he they get
another leak of this information like
that they know like the man confidential
information is just running loose out
here so I can I really blame him I don't
but I do say this to esa if you take my
application together we can make a team
he left four kids like that bad left o
addict here okay kids I leave just
synapses or this never get that Coliseum
thing when I was alright but my wife is
ready to go so we sat in anybody life
but but yeah I do agree with like the
whole thing it was like it was like the
way that it was announced was like oh my
god the industry this is a pretty much
an industry protest against the ESA
Saarinen on but somebody also brought up
another case is that Jeff Keely is now
competing directly with III mmm and in
trying to make obviously the game awards
to be that mm-hmm
go joke is now not only already hinted
now you know game of the Year awards and
stuff like that they are breaking news
and reveals and stuff like that I mean
what do we watch III for for like brand
new gameplay any new trailers
announcements and stuff like that and
obviously this year good we got the
announcement said right um and and he's
getting the views yeah so you know what
go ahead my bad kid might be onto
something no kid is definitely it might
not even be like a protest him
specifically might even be a protest
it's like look at the yeah I think
especially what they said the video game
award it was almost a tripled look look
at him he's a brand okay it might it
might be one of those things it's like
look like I don't want to I need to
separate my brain from your brain it
really might be that I didn't even think
about yeah and we all know yes too much
reach yeah we all know who's on that
he's got the whole school of the
industry on the game awards panel mmm
everybody thought that was since his
organization's probably bigger than he
300 not his events his organization
shout out the fallacy which at people
donate to smooth to help him pay his
lost bet to bond show Sony's shown an
ache a 120 FPS game to CES is ago Xbox
fair state losing games bets to play
stations or ps4 PC fail kid they they
coming for you for some reason I'd no
one that said Xbox will ship out of the
Xbox series in the play 65 the Xbox will
be the first one to ship a game that is
120 frames per second that's not VR know
bullcrap I'm sticking by that they're
gonna be have the first games to do is a
sucker bet Oh kid forfeited all out of
all the baby because I'm a changing you
could have won that what are you talking
about I quit that bet it was a hat like
me like eight beds or something like
that that's your brand if that's your
joint your joint that's your brand
meanwhile bets this did the crazy ragin
and stuff like that continue to get the
crazy ragin smooth or is this a new
vegan region in the streams of that's
difference my bit I'm talking my like if
like like for example like no like oh I
bet you that ps5 is gonna be $500 asking
like that yes a challenge I wouldn't say
so you just still in challenge mode you
just
all right so you got so you turned into
Sony in the bet pocket situation but you
know just just off the top of your head
how many how much money you think you've
lost them bet since you better like you
remember I had bonus which I sent like
hearty an Xbox
listen shout out the kids move being a
husband and the father that he is not
putting out that financial to get
him/her yes right we gotta go don't be
so anyway like we'll see what happens
you can say this if it goes Kings way
we're more content creators immediately
shall see and as far as III and ESA and
what the new direction is we do know we
do know media has its own day now get
these media people out they back cuz at
the end of the day having stuff leaked
I'm sure annoyed a lot of them and
especially some of the more extra extra
media was really like stressed but I
think the biggest majority of their
issues is the fact that they led in the
public yeah that kind of started the
thing we do agree so look we got this
poll they woulda just did the lake
without the letting in public I
guarantee you the majority of these
people wouldn't be saying yeah and they
handled it bad because remember the
public was stepping on top of the media
media didn't have enough time
they had like one hour it was a mess and
they did they didn't they didn't
introduce to part properly and that's
where things kind of just went down hire
me for security make sure that those
and we will definitely have new media
inside the building listen man yes we
have the number one provocateur with
[ __ ] about the round tables and
salute the king for making his sales
face so we got this poll we gotta get
out here bad log show with the potential
manufacturing cost of the PS 5 at 450 -
packaging shipping in retail what do you
think is the best price point for Sony
of the FT Xbox series X is 500 hours the
choices are a PS 5 she dropped to 400 to
undercut the Xbox series X and take a
loss on Hardware B PlayStation 5 should
profit at 500 they are still the bigger
global brand and market leader or C I
don't care about no hardware cuz it's
all about active users down there
everybody came through in the pile
people please rock it when it goes up
your saluted Jesus Ryan I came o one of
the biggest IOP guests in the bill
approach a problem a AZ comes in but
he's late when the show was ending damn
it you must have been at the hockey rink
but of your salute to Jason shrine man
outstanding outstanding show like I said
if you guys missed it
please catch the replay I'll go up
timestamps and all that good stuff will
go up and of course a little kid smooth
pulling up on that Xbox topics a little
small what do you got going on I heard
like 8:30 you know I appreciate like you
had had to bring it back no trying to
get back on my my grind you guys been
out here hustling but um no yeah nothing
nothing major going on do the podcast
every Wednesday I will be at PAX East I
heard yeah that's a we'll open day
that's what's up oh let's go be late man
so solution that's why I forgot I forgot
to super chat is like you know King
system i alerts for my PAX East
yeah we gotta get care might be saying
[Laughter]
salut is gonna be a lot of people got
bad bit up in there we got our three mg
B G you know says gonna be limp it's
gonna be up near my boy jeans and the
whole dog net is coming through your
smell don't King hide you don't say oh
it's gonna be late Hector is gonna be
there
we gonna have a bob done bro it's gonna
be let me so look out for the coverage
you see that yes a king making a TSA
pledge with loads again with that bit I
feel that bad but yeah it's gonna be let
man cut salut salut so um yeah man Lord
hear what you got going over five people
find you you can find me on Twitter and
Lord that it's P you can also find me on
youtube they gave me addicts mmm that's
with the uncensored addict is actually
this this podcast has rubbed off on my
youtube channel really nuts on there as
much as I used to face you know
definitely want to thank Jason strive
for coming on ain't thinking I ain't
thinking kid he kind of bullied himself
on here thank the chat the chat was lit
today you know it's you guys give us so
much support weekly and I have to really
really appreciate thank you guys
absolutely I was outstanding
Lord sovereign pulling up man always a
pleasure with what you got going on man
nothing big shout out this move for
coming to Australia I'm particularly
happy that we got Jason on the show fax
at this point in the lifetime of our
show because we as a podcast have grown
a lot to like when you talk about we
make comments about stuff we make jokes
or whatever and but often times and
which I think we've
we try to be fair right here but again
that fairness only extends as far as
your understanding of what you're
talking about right and I think our
understanding of what gaming into things
that happened around gaming I like how
you don't understand control right let's
not start with not doing it continue so
to have Jason on now and had that
perspective um I think we've gone to the
point we really respect a lot that he
does yes and one thing that I really
recognize is guys as gamers like we if
you're so passionate about this thing in
my feeling you have to be passionate
about every aspect about it you won't
have to know about everything you don't
mean like we love these games and
sometimes we feel like we want we want
we want and we're not paying attention
to human cost of yes we want we want we
want and you know the work that Jason
does the work that these guys do at
Kotaku and and other outlets as well is
very important we need to really be
cognizant of the stuff that is happening
around my favorite hobby we do mm-hmm
no I'm glad you said it the other day
it's so much that we don't know behind
the scenes you know as as people who
love this this hobby and this passion
and it's good to get that information
it's a little too - Jason we brought the
smoke and ETA run from me a lot of like
we gotta respect it cuz I get where the
Lord's are gonna be the Lord's King was
still King you know say like everybody's
out there so salute The Killers getting
about their next like what you got going
on salute to you for still getting your
provocateur you ain't changed up you is
in your bag I love I like you obviously
I can't go ahead to this cuz it's gonna
be fun and I was worried for sake ago
love cuz I know KK going back down you
know quiet King today on there
no shoutouts to jsr my kindred spirit um
after doing a lot of research like I saw
the yang Yang video and a lot of people
I don't go and watch per se but I was
doing the research on him because I
wanted to know about him a little bit
more yes right and in in and knowing him
a little bit more I understood that
stuff that he was saying you know wasn't
wrong with and I agreed without your
saying you know so as far as people feel
in a certain way about saying a
provocateur yeah um you are like and
don't don't take it in a negative sense
if somebody is classically trained in a
genre and an avenue and you invade their
space and you're not equally as trained
and you didn't do it that's hard work I
mean blood sweat and tears account for
something right I mean so uh you should
have felt the way oh he should feel a
certain way and certain things and I
agree that and I applaud to that because
listen I just decided to do this as you
know hanging out with my family my
friends their family he's decided to do
this when he was in school and he made
his dues so at what point of time is
that worth so here's a journalist I am a
pocket or this is the truth this is a
fact
um before we get started that dead joint
if you have not seen the video please go
check out Carroll West at Lourdes again
Manette I'm telling you right now I've
waited so long for this statue
shout out to season gaming Oh Bert is my
guy he he looked out for me yeah he sent
me a great quote and we worked it out
and I sent him the money ASAP you know
to get this statue here because he knew
it was gonna be in a loving home Bert if
you're watching I hope you see the
little shrine here now when I finish it
i'ma send you the pictures because I'm
definitely gonna put something together
for it very nice like I'm doing Thanos
oh wait I got another Thanos piece
coming in perhaps as to that one for
each cake salut today thank thank you so
much another another thousand dollar
piece
mati told me to get on my level in my
Twitter the other day and I had to laugh
at the young man you know I appreciate
you because you may not know who the
hell I am and you know I mean and I'm
winning your car equally in every
accomplishment in your life you supposed
to respect your accomplishments but
don't diminish others right and you're
supposed to be happy in your
accomplishment and don't envy anyone
else's nothing in here was given to me I
work very hard for everything here like
you work very hard for your stuff so
when I say king of statues
That's not me that's you you whatever
you have your collection you are the
king of your collection being proud of
your collection no matter how small or
matter how large cuz if you think this
is a lot of stuff here I see people in
my statue community there blow me away
and that makes millions of dollars a
year I do not make millions of dollars a
year okay so for me to look at them as
and admire them and they encourage me
and inspire me
I hope I'm inspiring youth I'm not doing
anything to put you down because I
understand that you work hard for every
buck and I'm fighting for you so when I
yell out game pass yes and I'm saving
money
please get game pass to and save cash
that's what's up man so Luther King on
that I was late and like I said that
interactions here Jason's classic mr.
Luther Jason again for coming through
not running from any question any topic
we even hit MIDI of bias we wish it was
smoking on that and oh yeah shout out to
that man shout to the chat y'all was
fantastic of course please support Lords
of gaming doubt net packs is coming soon
maybe with me yes yes we in the building
you know say so yes yes see that would
be a back soon we got one more we will
figure out what we're gonna do with that
but look man everybody please enjoy your
Sunday this is a fantastic episode let's
salute everybody to pulling up really
means a lot to us so Jason everybody
enjoy your Sunday we are out of here